il
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite voici les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce mardi 18 mai le chef
de la diplomatie de l'union européenne
appelle un cessez-le-feu entre israël et
palestiniens à l'issue d'une réunion en
réunion et également du côté du conseil
de sécurité de l'onu en france jean cas
cette demande à israël accès rapide et
sans entraves de l'aide à gaza sur le
terrain l'état hébreu a refermé le point
de passage humanitaire de kerem shalom
vers gaza après des tirs dos des géo
laurent sont exposés 7 me à argenteuil
dans le val d'oise des voitures ont été
incendiées des tirs de mortiers
d'artifice ont visé les forces de
l'ordre un épisode à la veille de la
marche citoyenne manifestation de
policiers prévus devant l'assemblée
nationale pour dénoncer les violences et
les derniers attentes envers les forces
de l'ordre gérald darmanin annoncé y
participer ce qui suscite quelques
critiques
emmanuel macron recevait aujourd'hui une
vingtaine de dirigeants africains dans
le cadre d'un sommet sur la dette et le
financement en afrique
à ses côtés ses homologues jordanien et
égyptien notamment objectif rétablir un
new deal avec le continent qui a subi à
cause du comité 19 sa première récession
en 25 ans
[Musique]
nouvelle réunion à huit clos aujourd'hui
du conseil de sécurité des nations unies
la quatrième en une semaine l'onu qui
appelle à ouvrir le point de passage
d'erez et ce après avoir salué
l'ouverture d'un premier couloir
humanitaire vers la bande de gaza mais
en raison de tirs d'obus
le jackpot checkpoints de kerem shalom a
été refermé par israël qui déplorent
deux nouveaux morts sur son territoire
après des tirs d'obus
de son côté paris par la voix de
matignon appel au calme et à permettre à
l'aide humanitaire d'être acheminée
correctement la france a appelé et
appelle de façon extrêmement ferme
l'ensemble des acteurs à mettre un terme
immédiat à toutes les violences à toutes
les provocations et à toute incitation à
la haine pour permettre un retour au
calme
nous appelons tous les acteurs tous les
acteurs à garantir l'accès rapide et
sans entraves de l'aide à gaza un convoi
humanitaire a été vous le savez autorisé
aujourd'hui et ce mouvement doit se
poursuivre nous demandons également à
tous de protéger le personnel
humanitaire et médicale
enfin la sécurité des journalistes et de
tous ceux dans l'expression concours à
la libre information et au débat public
et leur protection en temps de conflit
sont une responsabilité essentielle près
en cisjordanie l journée de colère avec
une grève à l'appel du fatah le parti du
président de l'autorité palestinienne
mahmoud abbas protestation aujourd'hui à
ramallah depuis dix jours le conflit
armé entre israël et le hamas a fait
environ 200 morts en grande majorité des
palestiniens
théo combat
nouvelle nuit et nouveaux bombardements
dans la bande de gaza aucun signe
d'accalmie ne semble apparaître alors
que le conflit entre israël et le hamas
entre dans sa deuxième semaine pour le
premier ministre israélien benyamin
nétanyahou les frappes aériennes dans le
micro territoire ne sont pas près de
cesser un drive la directive est de
continuer à bombarder les cibles
terroristes l'armée le fait très bien
aujourd'hui elle avise un commandant
supérieur du jihad islamique
nous avons frappé l'unité navale du
hamas et nous continuons à bombarder des
cibles souterraines le métro du hamas et
d'autres cibles
nous continuerons à prendre toutes les
mesures nécessaires pour rétablir le
calme et la sécurité pour tous les
risques dans d'israël une rhétorique
belliqueuse également reprise par le
hamas qui a envoyé plusieurs dizaines de
roquettes
hier sur le territoire israélien une
partie de ping pong armée dont les
populations civiles pâtissent avec plus
de 200 morts et des milliers de blessés
en majorité palestinienne
face à ce drame et pour la quatrième
fois depuis la reprise des hostilités
le conseil de sécurité doit se réunir en
urgence aujourd'hui mais l'onu semble
restée impuissante et en reste aux
déclarations d'intention
nous continuons à pousser activement
toutes les parties vers une cessation
immédiate des tirs entre israéliens et
palestiniens
notre coordinateur spécial torvalds
landes travaillent sans relâche avec
toutes les parties pour rétablir le
calme
une impuissance international symbolisée
par le refus américain à l'adoption
d'une déclaration du conseil de sécurité
à paulhan une cessation des violences
si joe biden sous la pression de son
camp a appelé à un cessez le feu hier
soir washington ne devrait pas changer
sa ligne de conduite dans les prochaines
heures
de notre point de vue nous nous
concentrons sur chaque action que nous
entreprenons chaque déclaration que nous
faisons dans les bus devraient du
la violence et de mettre fin au conflit
et sur le terrain il ya des moments dans
la diplomatie
nous devons garder ces conversations
discrètes un manque d'unité
international symbolisée par la
multiplication des initiatives lancées
pour tenter de résoudre le conflit
dernière en date celle d' emmanuel
macron et du président égyptien abdel
fattah al-sisi reçu lundi à l'elysée une
véritable cacophonie diplomatiques alors
que les tensions ne devrait pas
redescendre sur place le fatah parti du
président de l'autorité palestinienne
mahmoud abbas a ainsi appelé aujourd'hui
à une journée de la colère et de grèves
générales et ce conflit au proche orient
qui menacent de déstabiliser la
politique intérieure américaine depuis
le début de cette crise la maison
blanche.m plusieurs froid a rappelé le
droit d'israël à se défendre affichant
ainsi son soutien à l'état hébreu
mais devant le nombre de pertes civiles
et l'étendue des dégâts les élus
démocrates en tout cas certains d'entre
eux demandent un changement de posture
hadj aubade à chaque missile qui s'abat
sur gaza le mandat de joe biden se
complique alors que les échanges de tirs
entre les deux parties arrivent dans
leur seconde semaine
washington affiche toujours son soutien
à son allié breux le président a
également passé deux appels
téléphoniques au cours du week end et
lors de ses appels il a souligné que le
hamas devait cesser de tirer des
roquettes sur israël et a affirmé une
fois encore le droit d'israël à se
défendre contre les attaques terroristes
d'après les rapports plus de trois mille
roquettes ont été tirées par le hamas
sur israël au cours des derniers jours
les états unis empêche d'ailleurs
toujours l'adoption d'une résolution
contraignante au conseil de sécurité de
l'onu privant l'organisation d'un de ses
seuls moyens de pression bien que
washington se défendent de toute
obstruction
nous ne faisons pas obstacle à la
diplomatie au contraire comme je les dis
nous l'exerçons pratiquement sans
relâche
cheney la question est de savoir si une
action une déclaration donnée peut
réellement faire avancer l'objectif de
mettre fin à la violence et
aller vers un monde meilleur une
orientation que l'administration
américaine a pourtant de plus en plus de
mal à tenir en cause des voix
dissonantes en provenance du camp
démocrate qui réclame de la part de la
maison blanche une position plus
équilibrée
preuve en est ce courrier signé par 25
représentants démocrates et adressée au
secrétaire d'état anthony blinken
jérusalem est fait partie de la
cisjordanie et au regard du droit
international israël exerce une
occupation militaire de ce territoire
nonobstant son incorporation illégale de
jérusalem-est dans la municipalité de
jérusalem et son annexion illégale d
urée ultérieure de jérusalem est
les projets d'israël de démolir des
maisons palestiniennes à albou stands et
d'expulser des palestiniens de leurs
maisons à cheikh jarrah sont en
violation flagrante de la quatrième
convention de genève
deux jours plus tard le très populaire
sénateurs de gauche bernie sanders
enfonce le clou dans une tribune du new
york times depuis des années nous
assistons à une occupation israélienne
croissante de la cisjordanie et de
jérusalem est et à un blocus continue de
gaza qui rendent la vie des palestiniens
de plus en plus intolérable
nous avons vu le gouvernement de
benyamin nétanyahou s'employer à
marginaliser et à diaboliser les
citoyens palestiniens d'israël
nous devons reconnaître que les droits
des palestiniens sont importants
la vie des palestiniens comptent
palestinian ce live matters une tournure
parfum particulier outre-atlantique
illustration de cette nouvelle tendance
politique cette vente à israël pour 735
millions de dollars de bombes à guidage
de précision et qui a suscité une levée
de boucliers démocrate au congrès ces
appels à plus de sévérité à l'égard de
netanyahu joe biden ne peut les ignorer
le président américain ne disposent au
sénat que de la plus courte majorité
possible tout mécontentement de son camp
l'empêcherait d'appliquer son programme
la posture américaine critiquée jusque
dans quand même des démocrates alors
cette position soutien envers l'état
hébreu et elle tenait un blog pour joe
biden les états unis doivent-ils faire
évoluer leur position c'est d'objets de
notre décryptage ce soir pour en
débattre nous sommes nous avec kenneth
team hörmann ex conseiller aux affaires
étrangères de donald trump durant à la
campagne présidentielle de 2016 bonsoir
kenney timerman merci d'être avec nous à
vos côtés georges malbrunot grand
reporter au figaro spécialiste du
moyen-orient bonsoir georges malbrunot
merci aussi à vous d'être en direct ce
soir alors pas de déclaration commune un
de l'onu sur le dossier
israélo-palestinien plan à la cessation
des violences la chine regrette
l'obstruction des états unis c'est le
mot juste georges malbrunot on a vu qu
anthony blinken réfuté ans qualificatif
en tout cas les états unis ne veulent
pas gêner officiellement leurs efforts
diplomatiques et donc ils contre une
déclaration publique aux nations unies
on sait qu'il y à des initiatives qui
sont prises actuellement en coulisses il
y à un émissaire américain qui la barre
l'egypte le qatar également le kata
auprès du hamas l'egypte également essai
de 2,2 de trouver les voies et moyens
pour apaiser la situation mais on a vu
que t'es isréliens pour l'instant
benyamin netanyahou dit non à la
diplomatie il veut cesser terme enfants
philippe en tout cas continuer de on
voit bien un petit peu la stratégie
c'est après avoir eu après avoir
beaucoup bombardé notamment ce réseau de
tunnels
qui permet au hamas de se déplacer
aujourd'hui on est plus dans une
stratégie d'élimination cibler des
dirigeants pour que et bien toute cette
campagne de bombardements produisent des
effets et que il faille attendre
quelques années avant que le hamas ne
puisse se reconstituer à la fois ses
stocks de missiles et ses essais ses
dirigeants mais voilà on reste au jour
dans cette danse est problématique de
2,2 du glaive et du bouclier si je peux
m'exprimer ainsi tu mets la diplomatie
avance mais un petit pas qu'est l'acte i
man georges malbrunot ans qui connaît
évidemment parfaitement ce dossier en
parle l'élimination ciblée de la part
d'israël
il n'empêche en 200 morts pour la
plupart des palestiniens est ce que vous
vous comprenez en tant que bons
républicains malgré tout qu'il y ait
l'ouverture de ce débat y compris même
aux états unis
je suis agréablement surpris de voir la
position de l'administration bryden
d'habitude les dernières administrations
démocrates notamment aux usa obama
ils ont pris parti très franchement pour
les palestiniens et anti israéliens donc
moi je le jure est réjoui de ce que je
vois maintenant de la maison blanche
ceci dit il faut comprendre au congrès
yann larges majorités bipartisanes
démocrates et républicains ont soutien
de l'état hébreu c'est très très grand
et cette lettre que vous avez cités
avant qu'on ouvre le débat de vingt six
membres du congrès il faut noter que
parmi les signataires il y à un somalien
et kylie ann palestiniens il ya
plusieurs supporteurs du des frères
musulmans et une vingtaine de
socialistes donc ce n'est pas comme on
dirige le centre du parti démocrate mais
vraiment l'extrême aile gauche
alors avant de faire élire charge mais
vous ne voudrez vous faire écouter l'un
de ses représentants démocrates qui
critique
cette attitude de joe biden s'appelle
alexandria occasio cortès écoutez là
cela se produit avec le soutien des
états unis
je me fiche de la façon dont un
porte-parole essaie de tourner ça les
etats-unis ont opposé leur veto à
l'appel de l'onu pour un cessez le feu
si l'administration d'haydn ne peut pas
tenir tête à un allié acquis peut-elle
tenir tête
comment peuvent-ils prétendre de manière
crédible défendre les droits de l'homme
georges malbrunot notre ami
collectivement mais nous disait voilà
ces démocrates ont toujours pris parti
contre l'état hébreu m'enfin là ça
serait quand même une première tenir
vraiment tête à israël de la part des
états unis
ce serait inédit n'est ce pas oui dont
je crois que les démocrates n'ont pas
vraiment tenu tête à l'état hébreu il
faut rappeler que la dernière fois que
les états unis ont tenu tel justement à
l'état hébreu c'était en 1991 et je
crois si ma mémoire est bonne c'était
george bush père qui avait gelé les
garanties bancaires américaines au
profit d'israël pour intégrer les les
juifs qui émigraient d'union soviétique
et d'ailleurs ça avait marché ça avait
permis à israël ce avaient contraint
israël à accepter le processus de paix
qu avait été lancée à mariton lorsqu est
intéressant au jour aujourd'hui c'est
qu'on voit qu'au sein du parti démocrate
l'ailé gauche les jeunes aussi on a un
petit peu assez de ce soutien peut être
inconditionnel à israël que la
thématique des droits de l'homme qui a
été la thématique du du parti démocrate
et joe biden durant sa campagne et bien
aujourd'hui il en est un petit peu
prisonnier puisque by one l'homme ça
veut dire revient la table des
négociations et ont négocié la fin de
l'occupation de la cisjordanie et de
jérusalem est
donc ça c'est intéressant à signaler il
ya effectivement y compris d'ailleurs
loi au sein de la communauté junas
américaine une une une petite inflexion
pour ne pas tomber dans ce soutien
inconditionnel outrageusement pro
israéliens comme ça avait été le cas
sous donald trump qui était allé jeu
jusqu'à dont qu'on se perd et
l'ambassade américaine de tel aviv à
jérusalem faire en sorte que les états
unis redeviennent ce qu'ils avaient
souhaité être ce qu'ils avaient prétendu
est
dans l'ensemble le processus de paix
d'oslo en 1994
annonay ce broker ce qui d'ailleurs ils
n'ont jamais vraiment été puisqu'ils ont
en fait toujours soutenu israël qu elle
estimé remanié dans une drôle de
position quand même un joe biden comme
nous l'a très bien décrit georges
malbrunot il ya ce côté droits de
l'homme et il ya aussi l'opinion
américaine si on le sait est souvent
davantage pro israélienne avec une
communauté juive importante aux états
unis qu'elle peut quelle doit être
l'attitude de joe biden est ce qui peut
se prendre les pieds dans le tapis de ce
conflit
écouter beaucoup d'hypocrisie
on le voit quand on parle du droit de
l'homme et on est de gauche on oublie
les droits des femmes en l'état
islamique l'iran
on oublie le droit des cubains de
pouvoir voter de pouvoir s'exprimer on
oublie le droit d des hommes ont
venezuela et prix de nos régimes
socialistes donc il ya beaucoup
d'hypocrisie quand on parle des droits
de l'homme actuellement aux etats unis
il ya un large consensus et ce n'est pas
vous parler de la communauté juive la
culture juive aux etats unis c'est
plusieurs millions de personnes c'est 2%
de la population
c'est pas c'est pas plus important au
nombre que la communauté d'origine arabe
mais le consensus c'est parmi l'énorme
partie des chrétiens et notamment des
chrétiens évangéliques qui soutiennent
israël à 80 à 90%
donc ce n'est pas ce consensus il est
réel il est n'est pas le fait d'une
partie juive de la population d'ailleurs
dont la communauté juive il ya des
organisations de gauche qui soutiennent
à l'examen des occasions d'or qu'est ce
donc même la la communauté juive est
divisée anti israël et produisent rien
ce consensus est large va bien au delà
de la communauté juive et comprend les
chrétiens et surtout les évangéliques
aux états unis changent mais bruno
washington se défend finalement d'avoir
une approche voilà on sous marin avec
l'envoi de cet émissaire on imagine
qu'il ya beaucoup de coups de téléphone
en coulisses en ce moment entre
washington et israël et même les
territoires palestiniens est ce que cet
émissaire il peut faire davantage de
miracle qu une déclaration sans effet à
l'onu on va s'acheminer vers une fin des
hostilités
assez assez rapidement quand même parce
que vous avez vu israël il ya quelques
jours à à la déclarer l'imminence d'une
opération terrestre n'a jamais eu lieu
tant mieux parce que laisserait bien
savent très bien que c'est très
dangereux de d'or de pénétrer dans ce
petit territoire
la bande de gaza qui est densément
peuplées donc simplement les israéliens
ont des objectifs militaires qu'il
souhaite atteindre et côté hamas et bien
on veut montrer aussi con à résister
qu'on continue de résister on est
capable de tirer en dix jours 3400
qu'est ce qui est beaucoup plus que lors
de la dernière action de 2014
donc chacun doit montrer à son opinion
publique qui là qu'il a finalement gagné
je suis pas sûr que ce soit d y serait
bien qu'ils aient vraiment gagner parce
que le hamas a montrée justement par
rapport à 2014 ou par rapport à ja il ya
quinze ans que il avait une capacité
maintenant je dirais d'action grâce à
ces missiles qui ont une portée de
parfois 200 kilomètres plus bas qui le
qu'il instaurait un climat de tension et
de panique en israël et c'est l'objectif
qui recherchait donc voilà il faut il
faut qu' il faut on va en redevenir un
des nouveaux règles d'engagement
1 il va y avoir un grand un
cessez-le-feu bancal qui sera conclue
par l'égide sous l'égide des égyptiens
les services de renseignement égyptiens
sont très actifs à gaza l'egypte a des
contacts avec le hamas
le qatar qui finance la bande de gaza
qui est le sponsor politique du du hamas
est appelé à la rescousse et est cotée
au trial les israéliens eux sont en
contact avec les américains donc on va
s'acheminer vers une
vers une cessation des hostilités mais
le problème ne sera pas réglé pour
autant puisque ensuite eh bien tout ça
redeviendra entre guillemets normal la
bande de gaza qui continuera de subir un
blocus de million de palestiniens sur un
blocage de hamas continuera de régner en
maître sur cette bande de gaza et le
processus de paix sera toujours dans
l'impasse et c'est ça qu'il faut il faut
il faut arriver à le relancer
7c'est ces négociations pour en revenir
à l'origine du conflit c'est à dire un
conflit territorial entre israël et les
palestiniens sur l'occupation de la
cisjordanie et jérusalem est
vous êtes d'accord avec l'analyse kenney
timerman on va au final revenir au point
mort ça va être
voilà d'une certaine manière le point de
départ joe biden aujourd'hui n'est pas
l'homme de la situation comme l'a été en
son temps
bill clinton par exemple excusez moi je
rigole quand viendront parler de
l'occupation israélienne que la cij
ordonné les israéliens ils ont quitté la
cisjordanie à deux décennies ils ont
quitté gaza en 1994
je me souviens d'un voyage que j'ai fait
trois ans après elle les palestiniens
disait toujours il pouvait pas
reconstruire il pouvait rien faire à
cause de l'occupation israélienne il n'y
avait pas un juif sur le territoire de
gaza
à l'époque donc c'est un peu un barbare
de parler de l'occupation
georges malbrunot je vais vous faire et
on va peut-être pas refaire le construit
parce que voilà la base du débat c'est
le rôle des états unis mais pas de nier
l'histoire
israël a occupé gaza sont les retirer en
2005 israël continuait d'occuper la
cisjordanie et jérusalem est soit là ça
n'est pas être pro anti ou je ne sais
quoi c'est un fait historique c'est tout
voilà donc on peut pas contester sans
même israël ne le conteste pas alors je
vais vous faire écouter bernise louis
quantité de territoire que d'israël
occupa c'est vraiment mais discute mais
il ya une chose importante pour n'a pas
évoqué
c'est le soutien de l'iran le soutien
irons à gaza est la raison que hamas a
les roquettes qui sont cap
abl attirer à tel-aviv et au nord
d'israël c'est grâce à dire en les
iraniens ont cette capacité de se battre
jusqu au son du dernier un libanais ils
ont montré ça en 2006
et là ils vont se battre jusqu'au sang
du dernier paris signe à agen
non c'est pour ça qu'il faut que le il
faut qu'ils fassent la paix le hamas a
été en bisbille avec l'iran au cours de
ces dernières années était en conflit
parce que le hamas soutenait les
rebelles syriens contre bachar el assad
alors que l'iran était à mille de bachar
assad les encore et simplement comme les
rebelles anti syriens ont perdu l'iran a
été aux bleus le hamas a été obligé de
revenir un petit peu je dirais
piteusement 1 à téhéran pour que terran
continue effectivement de lui envoyer
les instructeurs militaires et c'est
donc la puye iranien il est
effectivement du hezbollah et de l'iran
il est il et il est évident et il est à
il est regrettable
bien sûr j'étais correspondant à
jérusalem ya vingt ans des roquettes du
hamas elle avait 2 km de portée la
nature ayant horreur du vide aujourd'hui
elle en jeu je dirais 100 fois plus 7
200 kilomètres donc le moralité il faut
revenir au processus de paix le statu
quo colline le statu quo n'est pas
supportable et il faut continuer à
avancer vers cette solution des deux
états un état palestinien qui vit aux
côtés d'israël dans des frontières sûres
et reconnues en sécurité voilà il n'y a
pas d'autre solution sinon on
recommencera se débat dans en trois ans
ou dans cinq ans et le hamas aura des
roquettes seront encore plus performante
et égaler gaza horno pape 2 millions
d'habitants mais trois millions
d'habitants il sera encore plus
dangereux pour l'état hébreu qui veulent
faire la paix quand vous avez une des
partie le hamas qui prêchent pas
seulement l'extermination de l'état juif
mais l'extermination des juifs
il n'y a pas possibilité de négociations
ont donné qu'on ne négocie pas avec
quelqu'un qui veut votre mère votre
extermination et pas vous
personnellement mais toute votre race to
votre peuple c'est à dire le génocide
normal c'est un c'est un mouvement
génocidaire
bruno c'est l'un des points
d'achoppement effectivement le hamas qui
est tout de même considérée comme une
organisation terroriste sur les listes
de l'union européenne est ce qu ont
négocié ce qu'on peut négocier
effectivement avec le hamas j'avais le
hamas les israéliens le connaît sur le
bout des doigts parce que il l'est ils
l'ont en partie formé entre 1967 et et
1987 lorsque pour contrer l'ol pedia
serra en fait ils ont laissé les
islamistes les mosquées se construire à
gaza ensuite lorsque la marque a été
créée en 1987 la plupart des dirigeants
étaient emprisonnées ou non en israël et
donc les israéliens le shin bet a été
roger je me souviens d'avoir rencontré
cheikh ahmad yassine des dizaines de
fois tu pas des dizaines mais enfin en
tout cas oui plusieurs dizaines de fois
et il avait fait de la prison en israël
ses collaborateurs aussi par les
protégera très bien le hamas il faut le
hamas n'est pas un mouvement djihadiste
il est un mouvement terroriste dont son
combat contre israël
il a évolué sur un certain nombre de
points y compris dans la reconnaissance
des frontières israélienne de 1967
et effectivement il vient bien sûr c'est
un mouvement un mouvement terroriste
mais si personne ne lui parle eh bien il
va se retourner encore plus vers l'iran
donc il ya bien un moment donné aussi il
faut c'est bien il faut savoir ce qu'on
veut de cette bande de gaza et les
palestiniens qui pensent que le vip soit
bande de gaza
ce loin s'en faut ne sont pas tous pour
le hamas qui exercent justement une mini
dictature sur eux mais il faut ré ouvrir
cette bande de gaza il faut trouver une
solution diplomatique économique pour
ces palestiniens et le hamas à partir de
la perdra de son aura perdra de son
influence il faut aussi que l'autorité
palestinienne mahmoud abbas
à 85 ans qui aujourd'hui est
complètement carbonisé accepte de passer
la main qui est de nouvelle génération
palestine bien que les israéliens libère
marwan barghouti et d'autre là il faut
tout ça et n'est pas inenvisageable
mouvement le hamas à sa demande de pays
la norvège la suisse discute avec avec
lui un certain nombre de pays arabes il
faut faire évoluer les choses
encore une fois la nature a horreur du
vide le statu quo est intenable et
plus on attend plus d'eux des radicaux
au sein du hamas vont prendre le peuvent
prendre le pouvoir
on a assisté à l'émergence c'est cette
dernière décennie dans sur la frange
dirais à droite du hamas si on peut dire
ça de gens qui sont devenus jihadistes
ils sont allés combattre avec l'état
islamique neige dans le sinaï
non voilà il faut bien sûr que le hamas
s'est pas des gens avec l'ailé qu'alors
on on irait passer nos vacances mais ils
sont là ils ont été créés sont
développés et ont prospéré sur le la
pauvreté sur l'impasse diplomatique
et bien aujourd'hui il faut il faut il
faut relancer un processus diplomatique
qui permettrait donc de dégonfler et de
réduire leur influence sur la société
palestiniens et leurs capacités
merci à tous les deux georges malbrunot
kenneth timerman d'avoir accepté ce face
à face en direction arte france merci à
vous restez avec nous dans quelques
instants nous parlerons des violences de
la nuit dernière à argenteuil en france
une cinquantaine de personnes ont tiré
des mortiers d'artifice en direction des
forces de l'ordre dans le quartier du
val d'argent et puis nous reviendrons
sur le sommet économique africain
comment la france va-t-elle aider le
continent à faire face à la crise
économique liée au comité
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus une pauvre
de défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire que notre peuple
c'était une volonté collective vous le
savez comme moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
des sous les libéraux l'uniforme c'est
quand même des hommes comment ces
mecs-là arrive à dormir la nuit là aussi
je pense qu'on a vécu quelque chose
d'inouï gilet jaune c'était des valeurs
de droite c'était des gens qui
travaillent c'est les gens qui avaient
envie de transmettre quelque chose à
leurs enfants
[Musique]
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas l'oublié
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est on dirait qu'il ya quand
même la liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
la repentance est un sentiment aux
conséquences extrêmement graves pour
l'avenir
cette pratique obsessionnel s'impose
dans l'esprit de nos dirigeants comme la
condition incontournable d'une
gouvernance responsable moderne plutôt
que de se repentir
on ferait mieux de faire référence à un
passé dont on peut être fier
nous trouvons un autre exemple des
limites de cette transparence dans
l'utilisation de la raison d'état pour
cacher la vérité sous la pression
médiatique et la raison d'état on
pratique une sélection du bien et du mal
à géométrie variable
il faut sauver la liberté d'expression
qui est prise en otage dans une
inversion entre le juste et le bien
[Musique]
20h30 sous lé bienvenu en direct sur rt
francs si vous nous rejoignez en france
les nuit dernière des voitures
incendiées des tirs de mortiers
d'artifice contre des policiers à
argenteuil dans le val d'oise
les pompiers sont rapidement intervenus
aucun blessé n'est à déplorer les
violences qui se sont déroulées dans le
quartier populaire du val d'argent au
quartier était originaire sabri décédé
il ya un an pile dans un accident de
moto à proximité d'une voiture de police
et des événements qui ont lieu à la
veille d'une marche citoyenne organisée
demain par les principaux syndicats
policiers
gérald darmanin annoncé hier qu'il y
participerait des milliers policiers qui
doivent donc se rassembler demain devant
l'assemblée nationale suite notamment à
la mort d'éric masson policier tué début
mai avignon lors d'une opération anti
drogue
le ministre de l'intérieur ne sera pas
le seul politique sur place ollier ford
ups ou encore jordan bardella du et
rennes ont annoncé aussi leur venue
gérald darmanin évoque pour sa part un
soutien nécessaire je serai présent
mercredi lors de cette manifestation
parce que c'est autant une manifestation
pour la république que celle des
policiers
la colère des policiers est légitime
quand ils sont attaqués sans cesse par
une partie de la classe médiatique
lorsqu'ils les ont connus depuis dix ans
le terrorisme dont ils ont été les
premiers ciblés
quand ils ont connu un an de violence de
la part d'une partie des gilet jaune
tout c'est samedi et pour en parler nous
sommes avec alexis poulain c'est notre
rubrique l'édito ce soir
[Musique]
alexis 1 le malaise dans la police
persiste un on le constate une
manifestation est attendue demain on l'a
dit le ras-le-bol qui est persistant
chez ces forces de l'ordre déjà pour
quelle raison le ras-le-bol il s'entend
on parle d'argenteuil
aujourd'hui c'est toutes les semaines à
peu près que la police ait pris pour
cible dans des guets-apens avec les
pompiers souvent lorsqu'ils sont en
intervention c'est le fait d'être
également pris pour cible par la menace
terroriste les terroristes islamiques
qui ont décidé de frapper simplement les
gens en uniforme
on se rappelle bien sûr c'était au plus
près de nous le commissariat de
rambouillet en deuil et puis le fait qu'
ils sont aussi mal aimés d'une partie de
la population parce qu'il faut le sale
boulot ils sont utilisés d'une façon
politique pour aller au clash avec les
manifestants plutôt que de protéger les
manifestants
il ya un problème aussi par rapport à la
façon dont l'ordre est organisée tout ça
fait qu'à un moment les policiers ont
effectivement ras-le-bol d'être
maltraités mal jugé mal vus par leurs
ministères mal encadrée et ce ras-le-bol
n'est pas neuf c'est à dire qu'on a
l'impression de voir quelque chose de
nouveau mais il n'a fait que monter ces
dernières années parce que il ya eu je
pense à un moment clé qui a été une
faille
rappelez-vous en 2005 quand on a eu
l'embrasement des banlieues les
l'élection de nicolas sarkozy en 2007
s'était fait un peu là dessus il était
ministre de l'intérieur à l'époque il
avait dit qu'il allait changer tout ça
et qu'est ce qu'il fait à ce moment là
et bien il réduit le nombre de postes de
fonctionnaires de police et il impose la
politique du chiffre la politique du
résultat qui fait que les policiers
n'étaient plus finalement dans
l'encadrement ou dans une politique
humaniste du maintien de l'ordre d'une
police républicaine mais une police du
chiffre et si ça fait aujourd'hui des
policiers en mal être avec
un nombre de suicides important dans
cette profession est une violence
permanente puisque c'est un métier qui
se confrontent quotidiennement à la
violence donc le ras-le-bol
il est compréhensible et malheureusement
je crois que les réponses de ce
gouvernement n'ont pas été à la hauteur
ces derniers mois alexi gérald darmanin
qui a donc annoncé manifester aux côtés
des syndicats beaucoup se demandent si
c'est vraiment la place d'un ministre de
l'intérieur c'est quand même assez
inédit c'est même cocasse que voir que
le ministre qui est mis en cause par les
syndicats manifestent finalement avec
les syndicats montrent la position de
faiblesse de ce ministre par rapport à
la force des syndicats de police
d'ailleurs le syndicat de police des
commissaires par la voix de son
secrétaire général
la ville de barr a dit clairement que
les politiques qu'ils ne participeraient
pas à cette manifestation devrait en
payer le prix
ou quelque chose qui s'approchait de
cette formule disant que tous les
politiques devraient être solidaires
derrière les policiers et d'ailleurs
fabien roussel du parti communiste
français a dit qu'il serait lui le
présent demain parce que la sécurité est
un thème important dans les quartiers
pour les classes les plus populaires et
c'est vrai que cette sécurité elle a été
abandonnée par de nombreux responsables
politiques de gauche qui pensaient que
elle n'était pas de leur ressort ou que
ça n'apportait pas assez de voir la
sécurité n'a pas de couleur politique
elle est même l'équivalent de la liberté
liberté et sécurité
il faut faire en sorte que les gens
vivent dans la concorde et sans avoir
peur quand ils sortent de chez eux et ça
ça n'a pas de couleur politique donc les
syndicats en sont très conscients ils
voient bien que les temps ont changé et
que après finalement le moment deux
d'entre deux où les populations ont été
plutôt peureuse dégoûté face à de
nombreuses violences policières lors des
manifestations du gilet jaune par
exemple les temps ont changé avec les
attentats avec le fait aussi qu'il est
nécessaire d'avoir une police
républicaine qui assurent la sécurité de
tous
donc ils en profitent ils disent que
maintenant les politiques doivent être
avec eux ou pas mais qu'un ministre
participe à une manifestation
là par contre c'est vraiment du racolage
et on est dans quelque chose
d'exceptionnel parce que le ministre
il est là pour répondre de ses actions
pour donner des moyens mais certainement
pas pour manifester avec les
manifestants ça s'est jamais vu alors
depuis un clément sossa remonte tout de
même quelques ministres de l'intérieur
on suit incarner la fonction à la
hauteur de l'état at on perdu tout sens
du régalien en france avec ce
gouvernement
oui c'est ce qui pose question c'est à
dire que quand on a un ministre de
l'intérieur qui finalement manifeste
c'est ubuesque
ou alors c'est roy lien mais ça n'a rien
à voir avec la force régaliennes
l'autorité de l'état qui est rabâché
d'ailleurs à longueur de plateau en
disant il faut le retour de l'autorité
mais c'est pas en manifestant avec des
syndicats policiers qu'on va remettre
l'autorité au coeur de l'état on a
l'impression que cette fonction s'est
délité avec le temps vous parliez de
clemenceau qui était à un ministre de
l'intérieur iconique qu'il y en ait
d'autres
tout le monde se rappelle de charles
pasqua ce qu'il a fait aussi à
l'intérieur était particulier c'est une
fonction difficile puisqu'on doit
assurer l'ordre mais aussi assurer les
élections assuré aussi l'organisation de
la laïcité à la française qui est une
exception internationale donc c'est
vraiment une charge très lourde sur les
épaules d'une seule personne manuel
valls qui étaient remises de l'intérieur
peut-être trop ambitieux qui voulait lui
très vite monter les échelons et souvent
un ministre de l'intérieur c'est
quelqu'un qui a en tête un avenir
politique
rappelez-vous et nicolas sarkozy il est
longtemps ministre l'intérieur et il
prépare sa campagne pour devenir
président c'était en 2007 c'est pour ça
que je vous parle un peu de ce hiatus
par rapport à ce qu'il s'est passé dans
les banlieues on a eu ensuite
aujourd'hui gérald darmanin qui est
finalement le fils spirituel ou c'est
ainsi qu'il aimerait se positionner de
nicolas sarkozy mais qui certainement
n'aimait pas à la hauteur compte tenu de
cette déclaration de vouloir manifester
avec les manifestants quand on est
ministre on ne manifeste pas on répond
aux revendications des syndicats mais
certainement pas ça et c'est la preuve
que ce gouvernement ne comprends pas
quel est le rôle d'un gouvernement c'est
d'assurer l'autorité de l'état
les fonctions régaliennes et aujourd'hui
on est dans la communication à tout va
dans le clientélisme à tout va et c'est
inquiétant et pour l'état et pour les
citoyens français qui se demande
finalement
s'ils sont gouvernés ou si ils ont
affaire à un personnel politique en
campagne permanente et on a l'impression
qu'aujourd'hui
et bien ça y est la campagne
présidentielle ayant commencé c'est la
campagne permanente et il n'y a plus de
ministre ni de pilote dans l'avion
tout le monde est vent debout derrière
mails macron pour le pousser vers sa
candidature pour 2022 merci beaucoup à
alexis poulain éditorialistes d'avoir
été en direct avec nous emmanuel macron
a reçu à paris aujourd'hui une vingtaine
de chefs d'état africains pour un sommet
sur le financement et la dette de
l'afrique objectif mettre en place un
new deal pour relancer l'économie du
continent
walid ben c'est une valse de présidents
africains pour un concert de futures
décisions décisives
emmanuel macron a accueilli ce lundi sur
le perron de l'elysée des dirigeants
d'états africains européens et du golfe
ainsi que d'organisations
internationales
le président français tout heureux
d'annoncer une bonne nouvelle pour le
soudan la france a décidé d'annuler sa
créance envers son pays alliés soit près
de 5 milliards de dollars un cadeau
après qu'un soulèvement populaire a
conduit à la chute de l'autocrate omar
el-béchir par l'armée en 2019 vous avez
choisi d'unir nos forces civiles et
militaires pour faire réussir votre
révolution
vous l'avez fait avec l'appui de l'union
africaine dont je salue ici le rôle
subtil et décisif la réduction de la
dette soudanaise que nous allons amorcer
prochainement est un premier résultat
il conviendra que cette trajectoire de
retour du sud en dans le concert des
nations soit confortée au plan
économique
au plan politique la france est
également engagée à prêter 1,5 milliard
de dollars au soudan sous la forme d'un
prêt relais pour lui permettre de
couvrir ses arriérés vis-à-vis notamment
du fonds monétaire international et je
suis sûr qu'avec ce type d'engagement le
peuple soudanais avance dans la bonne
direction avec le soutien de nos
partenaires
mais une conférence internationale pour
le soudan mis en place dans le cadre
d'un sommet sur le financement des
économies africaines en temps de crise
sanitaire et économique traité analyser
et résoudre le fardeau de la dette pour
des pays riches en ressources
pétrolières minières ou gazière
principal objectif de ce rassemblement
important
ce dernier organisée après que le fonds
monétaire international a tiré la
sonnette d'alarmé en octobre 2020 le
continent est en effet sur le point de
connaître un déficit de financement de
290 milliards de dollars d'ici 2023
selon la banque africaine de
développement en 2021 39 millions
d'africains pourrait également tomber
dans l'extrême pauvreté
des chiffres qui inquiètent comme tout
autant l'initiative française sur le
terrain
le spectre du colonialisme reste très
présent que c'est que de là que la
france nous octroie ce sont des crédits
conditionné conditionné on vous donne de
l'argent en contrepartie sont nos
entreprises qui vont gagner les marchés
et donc avec parfois des stratégies pour
tuer ton était plus vert national et
aussi permettre à l'état aussi d'être
dépendant de la france parce que si vous
devez de l'argent à la face ou devenir
dépendant de la france est
continuellement en exploite de manière
très intelligente
les pays africains au détriment
maintenant du secteur privé local
aujourd'hui face à la multiplication des
variants du coc vie 19
la majorité des pays africains réclament
un moratoire immédiat sur leur dette
extérieure jusqu'à la fin de la pandémie
et pour parler de ce sommet nous sommes
avec raï aide chez ibi président de
l'association pour la promotion de la
coopération et de l'amitié entre la
france et la tunisie
bonsoir rail est chez ibi l'économie
française un petit peu en perte de
vitesse en afrique au profit d'autres
pays comme par exemple la chine ce
sommet certes mondiale mais à
l'initiative de la france ce n'est pas
un moyen pour l'hexagone de servir ses
intérêts financiers
le pansement
je le pense pas parce que les liens
entre le la france et l'afrique et
notamment depuis que le président
emmanuel macron est arrivé au pouvoir on
sait qu'il a fait de l'afrique un
partenaire privilégié et que surtout il
a un regard qui est assez nouveau de sur
les relations que doivent avoir la
france avec l'afrique avec la nécessité
de soutenir l'économie africaine de
soutenir sa jeunesse qu'est la véritable
richesse du continent
donc le fait que la france soit
l'initiative d'un d'un événement
international et d'un sommet aussi
important pour la relance économique
africaine je ne pense pas que ce soit
une très mauvaise idée est au contraire
c'est ça permet justement d'impulser une
nouvelle dynamique pour un continent qui
en a bien besoin pour relancer
l'économie africaine vaste programme le
projet de s'annonce titanesque vu la
taille et les disparités du continent à
quoi faut-il s'attendre pour vous il ya
une forme d'efficacité on est obligé la
crise la crise sanitaire que nous avons
vécu a vraiment marqué à la fois les
esprits mais surtout à marquer notre
économie la france était très durement
frappé l'afrique également je rate
juste les chiffres qui ont été dits
d'ailleurs lors du reportage cette crise
va entraîner l'extrême pauvreté de 39
millions dhs africaine et d'africains et
si nous faisons rien ça va empirer
donc le fait d'organiser une initiative
par la voie multilatérale en associant
des pays de tout le continent des pays
du maghreb des pays d'afrique de l'ouest
des primes d'afrique centrale ou du sud
avec aussi et c'est ça qui est important
des grandes institutions financières et
bancaires internationales c'est la
volonté vraiment d'impulser quelque
chose de nouveau donc oui c'est très
important je rappelle que cette crise
sanitaire que nous avons vécue et que
nous continuons de vivre aura un impact
a déjà un impact économique social et
surtout bien sûr sanitaire donc j'ose
espérer que de ce sommet va ressortir à
la fois bien sûr des mesures concrètes
comme la réduction ou l'effacement de la
dette c'est ce qui est d'ailleurs
puisque je suis président d'une
association qui oeuvre à promouvoir la
coopération d'amitié entre la france et
la tunisie
je salue d'ailleurs la déclaration qui a
effectué le le président de la
république tunisienne en ce qu'il disait
que l'endettement représente l'un des
principaux obstacles à la relance
économique
je le pense aussi donc j'ose espérer que
deux ce sommet ressortira des
propositions concrètes permettant à la
fois de réduire la dette de certains
pays africains voire de ceux qui en ont
vraiment besoin
mais en garde mais entendent impulser
une nouvelle dynamique permettant une
reprise économique significative du
continent africain vous le dites à
l'afrique avec un des chiffres
impressionnants liées à la crise
sanitaire et pourtant le continent a été
relativement épargné par la crise du duc
o vite comment expliquer bas
effectivement quand on quand on regarde
les chiffres il ya eu 130 mille morts
même si même si on considère que le
continent était a été épargné c'est
quand même 130 mille victimes et on ne
peut avoir que que penser et et regrets
pour les familles qui ont été
endeuillées je pense que le pays et que
le continent pardon à a plutôt bien
résisté parce que beaucoup de mesures
ont été prises quasiment immédiatement à
lhassa
le confinement pour bon nombre de pays
donc des mesures très rapides très
concrètes ont été prises et je pense que
c'est aussi ça qui a sauvé quelque part
l'afrique
d'une on va dire d'un cataclysme
sanitaires pour autant pour autant c'est
aussi l'arbre qui cache la forêt parce
que même s'il ya eu très peu de victimes
en afrique mais des victimes quand même
il n'en demeure pas moins que ça a mis
en exergue les inégalités d'accès à des
soins de qualité mais surtout mais
surtout d'avoir des des structures des
infrastructures médicales de qualité et
c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ose
espérer que de ce sommet c'est un appel
d'ailleurs que je lance à l'ensemble des
chefs d'état d'afrique et au président
de la république emmanuel macron c'est
de faire en sorte que les
investissements qui vont être décidée je
l'espère pour l'afrique permettent
également de d'investir massivement dans
le comment dirais-je dans le secteur
sanitaire mais également dans
l'éducation parce qu'on voit bien que
abbaye confiné c'était aussi
malheureusement et en particulier pour
l'afrique
une coupure entre les enfants et le
monde éducatif donc la nécessité
d'investir la dent sur c'est sur ces
deux thématiques et sur ces deux
domaines
justement qui vient investissements
disent beaucoup attiré des investisseurs
privés dans ces pays africains c'est en
tout cas ce qu'estime emmanuel macron ça
serait l'une des solutions pour relancer
la croissance économique africaine cela
vous paraît dans le domaine du possible
oui ça peut être possible mais il faut
aussi investir dans les tpe pme qui sont
présentes en afrique parce que
l'économie et la relance économique du
continent se fera bien sûr par une aide
significative de la part des bailleurs
internationaux qui je l'espère joueront
leur rôle pleinement
mais il faut aussi soutenir ceux qui
sont les acteurs le pont modèle
économique du continent
tu les tpe les pme qui investissent
massivement et qui de leur énergie de
leur temps cette jeunesse comme disait
le président de la république c'est une
jeunesse créative dynamique pour
l'exemple de la tunisie pays que je
connais le mieux mais c'est pareil en
côte d'ivoire c'est pareil au mali c'est
pareil en afrique du sud c'est pareil en
république démocratique du congo
l'afrique
elle a une richesse qui
sa jeunesse il faut investir avec elle
et ça me permet elle votre question me
permet également d'avoir cette la
réflexion suivante et je dirais même la
proposition suivante
je pense que dans ce type de sommets qui
encore une fois est un suaire est un
sommet qu'il faut saluer parce qu'on met
en valeur le multilatéralisme
je pense qu'il faut aussi promouvoir ce
que j'appelle moi le multilatéralisme
sybille c'est-à-dire faire en sorte d'
associer avec ses chefs d'état et
gouvernement les acteurs de la société
civile ceux qui font l'économie
africaine mais également ceux qui
s'investissent pour promouvoir
je dirai ce que j'appelle également
diplomatie associative c'est à dire
comment dirais-je associer tous les
talents de la société civile des
fondations des entreprises et faire en
sorte d'apporter aux côtés des chefs
d'état de gouvernement des solutions
concrètes pour le continent donc soumis
à ce sommet des chefs d'état de
gouvernement mais il je pense qu'il faut
élargir aux acteurs économiques du
continent parce qu'ils connaissent
parfaitement
je dirais le le les problématiques et la
nécessité de d'investissement et surtout
la nécessité de 2 comment dirais-je de
sortir de la crise dans laquelle nous
vivons
mais je pense également qu'il faut
associer les autres acteurs de la
société civile qui sont tout aussi
engagée pour l'afrique est qui et qui
aime aussi ce continent parce que c'est
aussi le nôtre
vous parliez de l'annulation de la dette
en africains pour laquelle vous vous
plaidez l'année dernière d'ailleurs à
emmanuel macron [ __ ] également pour cette
annulation aujourd'hui le président
français parlerait plutôt d'un new deal
c'est un revirement vous vous
l'expliquez comment c'est peut-être
aussi la volonté de certains et pays
d'afrique parce que quand vous regardez
le continent vous avez effectivement
certains pays qui nécessite à ce qu'il y
ait un effacement de la dette
vous avez pris le cas tout à l'heure il
me semble delà de la somalie je crois et
vous avez d'autres d'autres pays qui eux
nécessitent ou réclame uniquement une
réduction massive de la dette ça dépend
en fonction des pays certains pays s'en
sont mieux sorties que d'autres aussi
bien économiquement que financièrement
donc
à chaque pays sa propre place à sa
propre problématique pardonnez-moi mais
le j'ai envie de dire que le point
commun de tout ça c'est que
économiquement il ya besoin d'avoir
d'avoir une relance et donc quand vous
prenez un pays extrêmement pauvre comme
le soudan s'est pas forcément la même
problématique que si vous prenez un pays
comme la côte d'ivoire ou bien je la
république démocratique du congo qui ont
des ressources naturelles qui leur
permet malgré tout de faire face aux
difficultés pour que killing réductions
massives
oui et qui est un effacement pour
d'autres pays oui également merci rien
de chez ebay d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur arte france est à noter que
les participants au sommet sur les
économies africaines ont demandé
officiellement la levée des brevets sur
les vaccins ce soir c'est emmanuel
macron lui-même qu'il annonce maintenant
le reste de l'actualité en france les
fonderies mbf à saint-claude dans le
jura on sur 6 280 emplois en jeu est les
salariés bloquent leur site depuis le 31
mars les attendent désormais la décision
du tribunal de commerce de dijon et doit
statuer sur le maintien au nom de la
fermeture de l'usiné sur place renault
parquet avec maxime inverse 48 jours que
le bras de fer dure depuis le début de
la grève
aucune pièce de moteur ne sort de la
fonderie mbf qui fournit notamment
renault et peugeot malgré les
engagements pris par les deux
constructeurs français
l'inquiétude gagne les salariés depuis
que la direction d'edm bf a été évincé
force est de constater que psa plus ou
moins maintiendrait ses engagements
horreur mais renault c'est la
dégringolade je vais dire ça comme ça
puisque à partir de 2023 désengage
totalement de la fonderie alors qu'ils
ont des engagements jusqu'en 2026 à
hauteur de 15 millions d'euros de
chiffre d'affaires par an de leur côté
les élus locaux se mobilisent pour
offrir des garanties et accompagner
salariés et entreprises plusieurs
propositions de reprise ont été
transmises mais une seule jugé fiable et
pérenne par le tribunal de commerce de
dijon
avec le maintien de 229 s'est dit au
lieu de 280 sur le candidat qui reste en
liste je pense qu'il a donné toutes les
assurances possible pour nous sécuriser
et sécurisé notamment l'intersyndicale
pour la viabilité de son projet donc on
a effectivement bon espoir d'arriver
les collectivités ont pris des
engagements et des engagements forts qui
doivent aussi aidé le tribunal à prendre
ces décisions
et maintenant on attend aussi beaucoup
des constructeurs pour qu'ils tiennent
leurs engagements
autre option la mise en liquidation de
l'entreprise
une solution qui plongerait la ville en
plein désarroi économique dans une
région déjà impacté par les
délocalisations
c'est une entreprise historique de la
ville on ne peut même pas imaginer que
nous perdions quasiment 300 emplois ce
qui veut dire une des familles
représentent 1000 personnes en
difficulté guy roux qui auront beaucoup
de mal à retrouver de l'emploi sur place
c'est donc catastrophique à la fois pour
les villes de saint claude à leurs
familles bien entendu le 14 avril
dernier les salariés avaient écrit au
ministère de l'économie pour
l'interpeller sur la situation de la
fonderie sans réponse
cinq d'entre eux ont donc rejoint paris
aujourd'hui ils vont entamer une grève
de la faim devant bercy quelques
instants sur la réouverture des
terrasses et des musées ce mercredi nous
irons à la rencontre du patron d'un
restaurant qui prépare sa journée de
demain non sans galère et puis nous
parlerons du rapport quitté commandé par
emmanuel macron pour évaluer les forces
et faiblesses de la stratégie française
face à la crise sanitaire
[Musique]
le terme banlieue voir l'intensité c'est
forcément péjoratif c'est vrai que les
médias ont un regard on va dire assez
particulier des banlieues et qui dérange
aujourd'hui et en donne ses narrations
de la banlieue ça se résoudrait cas des
jeunes violents contre une police qui
serait son travail c'est plus compliqué
que ça on est français on est fiers de
vivre dans ces quartiers même si à des
difficultés et la moindre des choses
c'est d'inscrire aussi notre empreinte
quand on participe à la vie de la
société et malheureusement il n'y a pas
cette reconnaissance
aujourd'hui je pense que le changement
viendra d'abord à travers cette
conscientisation des citoyens des
quartiers populaires on parle également
des deux zones de reconquête
républicaine
au final derrière ces mots qu'est ce qui
casse qui se cachent des politiques font
pour les gens mais sans les gens c'est à
dire qui donne cette impression de faire
de vouloir changer les choses mais
concrètement politiquement ils ne le
font pas
[Musique]
bienvenue à novossibirsk sommes au bord
de la volga le plus long fleuve d'europe
nous sommes à chez vox harry
allons faire connaissance
vous avez choisi le jour à ba là on est
alors je suis arrivé en 2005 pour
étudier dernière fois celle en france
étaient en 2011
elle me demande pas un petit peu non ah
oui et c'est tous les fromages tous les
soucis sont toutes les les croissants la
pâtisserie traits de caractère des
russes qui te plaît l'amitié les gens
les gens très stylée les français ne
savent pas je ne pensais jamais de ma
vie faire la cour j'ai enseigné
vous pouvez me souhaiter bon courage
[Musique]
à très bientôt sur arte france
arrivé du coc vite 19 annie bon nombre
d'entreprises en difficulté comment les
sauver faut-il annuler la dette de
certaines entreprises l'annulation de la
dette aura des conséquences et il faut
le savoir y aura des conséquences avec
les banques banques qui étaient déjà pas
bien en avant la crise du coc vide cette
idée de prendre en charge les les la
dette des entreprises
pour moi c'est un peu c'est plus
proportions gardées c'est un peu c'est
simple vaccin du bienheureux pourquoi au
final on aura exactement comme
d'habitude les mêmes qui vont payer
c'est à dire tous ceux qui payent des
impôts
monsieur bruno le maire se prend pour un
type ex il veut y passer toutes les
dettes les dettes de l'état les dettes
des entreprises etc stark
simplement si on se posait la question
de ne pas aller faire ça serait déjà pas
mal
[Musique]
vous êtes renversé par un homme de 92
ans qui perd le contrôle de son véhicule
deux ans et demi plus tard vous vous
imposez comme un espoir français du
tennis fauteuil objectif est les jeux
paralympiques de paris directeur le
sport m'a toujours sauver le tennis
c'est que c'est mon sport
bon il ya un fauteuil mais je vais
essayer en fait je me suis rendu compte
que ça allait c'était suffisamment
physique pour moi j'ai une vie de
sportif de haut niveau je m'entraîne
tous les jours c'est devenu ma vie la
raison de me lever le matin j'avais
toujours ce vieux rêve de petite fille
de faire du sport de ma vie est
finalement là c'est c'est ce que je
réalise avec le jambon moi j'ai un autre
combat on ma vie qui est celui de la
sécurité routière s'agit d'un projet de
loi qui vise à mettre en place des tests
d'aptitude pour tous les conducteurs pas
seulement les seniors on a un contrôle
technique de son véhicule
il faut un contrôle technique de sa
personne et sa l'état doit doit imposer
loi sur ce sujet là
[Musique]
le ms a exhorté certains pays d'afrique
à ne pas détruire les vaccins anti
qu'ovide périmés il faut craindre une
vaccination low cost en afrique l'on une
vaccination est une vaccination savez la
vaccination ce n'est pas elle n'a pas
commencé avec la corrida
le problème ça reste quand même
l'approvisionnement reste que c'est la
faute des pays les plus riches qui
accapare justement les productions de
l'accent où est le mécanisme de la
vaccination vous savez ça a soulevé
beaucoup d'enjeux sur la question de la
solidarité si on peut en faire plus en
terme de solidarité de partage de ces
vaccins là c'est quelque chose
d'absolument important on sait que le
nigeria affirme qu'il élabore son propre
vaccin contre le coc u19 pour en finir
avec justement la dépendance vis-à-vis
des laboratoires un étranger que ce soit
le sénégal le nigeria l'afrique du sud
beaucoup de pays en cette ambition-là
devoir amener l'agenda de la santé
publique au top des priorités c'est
quelque chose que nous saluons
énormément au niveau de l'organisation
[Musique]
vingt-et-une personnes de rejoindre pour
cette deuxième heure d'émission tout de
suite voici les titres de l'actualité de
ce mardi 18 mai est ce les prémices du
retour de l'art de vivre à la française
comme le promet bruno le maire plus que
quelques heures en tout cas à patienter
avant la réouverture des terrasses et
musées mais attention il faudra composer
avec des jauges fixé à 50% de
l'occupation habituel dans cette
émission zoom également sur le rapport
sur la gestion de crise commandé par
emmanuel macron paru aujourd'hui 4000
migrants renvoyés par madrid vers le
maroc au lendemain sur les huit mille
exilés débarquer dans l'enclavé
espagnole de ceuta un afflux migratoire
jugé inquiétant par la commissaire
européenne aux affaires intérieures le
maroc de son côté décide de rappeler son
ambassadrice en espagne pour
consultation les nuisances sonores des
consommateurs de drogue dans le quartier
stalingrad de plus en plus difficile à
supporter par les habitants du 19e
arrondissement de paris la préfecture a
donc décidé de regrouper les toxicomanes
sur les eaux de jardin d'eole d'une
solution très critiqué par les riverains
[Musique]
le pass sanitaire examiner cet après
midi par les sénateurs un document
approuvé dans la douleur la semaine
dernière par les députés ce sésame doit
permettre de participer aux événements
de plus de 1000 personnes ainsi que la
libre circulation dans la zone euro il
est censé comporter l'attestation d'une
vaccination anti coville ou un test pcr
négatif datant de moins de 72 heures une
proposition de loi qui suscite de
nombreuses interrogations l'opposition
évoque elle une mesure liberticide et
pour en parler on retrouve tout de suite
en direct c'est mme shelly devant le
sénat bassem première lecture donc au
palais du luxembourg après que le sénat
a adopté hier en commission sa version
du projet de loi qui accompagne le
déconfinement effectivement stéphanie
après des débats houleux à l'assemblée
nationale les sénateurs se sont emparés
de ce projet de loi sur la sortie de
crise sanitaire ici en france les
sénateurs qui l'ont adopté déjà hier en
commission mais les discussions ont
commencé cet après midi au palais du
luxembourg
la majorité sénatoriale de droite comme
du centre veut aller plus loin que ce
qui a été fait par les parlementaires au
palais bourbon notamment en apportant
des modifications à ce texte qui a été
validé par les députés
au passage le rapporteur de la
commission le député lr philippe le
sénateur pardon lr philippe leuba veut
prolonger l'état d'urgence sanitaire du
2 au 30 juin date à laquelle le
gouvernement estime ne plus avoir besoin
de recourir au couvre feu pour contenir
la diffusion de l'épidémie les régimes
de sortie d' état d'urgence sanitaire
permet lui à peu près tout au
gouvernement sauf un confinement el
nacional il donne aux gouvernements ont
des pouvoirs d'exception comme la
limitation du droit de circuler
librement ou la fermeture de certains
établissements publics
c'est pour ça que les sénateurs
souhaitent vraiment travailler autour de
ce texte pour contenir bien sûr tous les
pouvoirs du gouvernement face à sa
sortie le de crise les dates du
couvre-feu elle fixé à 21h puis à 23
heures à partir du 9 juin prochain ont
été précisés dans ce projet de loi avec
toute une série de mesures relatives à
ceux des confinement
prochain voilà ce qui attend les
sénateurs depuis cet après midi et ce
jusqu'à tard dans la nuit et peut-être
demain et bassel les sénateurs qui ont
modifié dansait déjà l'article 20 qui
porte notamment sur le controversé parce
sanitaire au coeur de toutes les
polémiques
effectivement stéphanie c'est vraiment
l'article 1 qui pose problème qui a fait
polémique déjà l'assemblée nationale les
sénateurs quand ils ont récupéré ce
texte ils se sont concentrés sur cet
article
l'article 1 qui porte notamment sur ce
pass sanitaires les deux chambres
l'avait rejetée déjà l'assemblée
nationale et député modem avait déclaré
rejeter cet article 1 dénonçant un texte
trop flous sont eux je vous rappelle
juste que cet article 1 comporte toutes
les prérogatives relatives aux passes
sanitaire a pas sanitaires dont le terme
n'apparaît pas il faut le dire dans le
texte il permet de limiter l accès à
certains lieux qui accueillent beaucoup
de monde à condition soit d'être
vaccinées soit de le prouver un test pc
en négatif ou une attestation de sortie
de contamination au kobus 19 si les
sénateurs globalement sont d'accord avec
le principe ils ont voulu où ils ont
déclaré vouloir circonscrire ce pass
sanitaires à philippe bas encore une
fois le porte le rapporteur et l'air de
cette commission propose de différencier
entre les endroits et extérieur les
endroits intérieur et précise clairement
que le pass and i ter ne peut être mise
en oeuvre que pour les lieux où
événements impliquant un grand nombre de
personnes à savoir plus de 2000
personnes donc il faut savoir que cet
article un divise la classe politique
français que ce soit au sénat ou même à
l'assemblée nationale ici au sénat le
sénateur de haute-savoie
loïc hervé a même déposé un amendement
pour supprimer à certains articles 1
tout comme la sénatrice et présidente du
groupe communiste
eliane à 6,6 merci ben hassen chébili
pour toutes ces précisions en direct
donc du palais
luxembourg à paris et à la veille de la
réouverture des commerces musée et
terrasses ainsi que des bars et des
restaurants la mission indépendante
menée par le professeur suisse didier
pittet a présenté le rapport de sa
mission d'évaluation sur la gestion de
la crise ducobu 19 par le gouvernement
voici ce qu'il faut en retenir avec
grace day à l'heure de vérité a sonné ce
mardi la mission indépendante nationale
a publié son rapport objectif jauger la
manière dont le gouvernement français à
appréhender cette crise pour pouvoir
mieux anticiper une nouvelle épidémie
virale dès le premier rapport déposé en
octobre dernier
le constat était similaire un énorme
manque d'anticipation face à la crise
sanitaire
ce rapport final confirme que le niveau
de préparation à la crise sanitaire
était faible mais a pu être compensée
grâce à la mobilisation des agents
hospitaliers et d'autres acteurs de
santé sont notamment mis en cause une
prise de décision tardive sur la
nécessité du port du masque qui a causé
une pénurie lente mise en place de la
stratégie de test et difficultés à
décentraliser les décisions propres à
chaque foyer de contamination pour les
experts d octobre 2020 des décisions
auraient pu être prises pour didier
pittet responsable de la mission si la
france n'a pas été au rendez vous
l'europe n'est pas en reste
cette transformation a été spectaculaire
maintenant évidemment on aurait tous pu
faire mieux
l'organisation mondiale de la santé a
souvent été lente l'europe n'a pas été
au rendez vous au départ mais s'est
rattrapé ensuite si le confinement était
nécessaire il a eu de graves
conséquences économiques pour la france
déjà très endetté dans la zone euro mais
si le gouvernement est parvenu à
maintenir les revenus des ménages les
travailleurs indépendants ont été très
touchés et ont eu très peu accès aux
aides du gouvernement
l'un c'est une perte d'activité sans
précédent qui va peser sur les finances
publiques et accentuer la position
défavorable de la france déjà très
endetté dans la zone euro l'impact
social de la crise
difficilement mesurable devraient être
multiples et durable vont rater
également la vaccination avec une
modification de la stratégie vaccinale
et une communication basée sur la
prudence qui a pu se révéler inadapté un
rapport finalisé par une liste de
quarante propositions pour une meilleure
préparation aux éventuelles futures
prises avec une plus grande place donnée
à la santé publique et l expertise
scientifique
parmi les propositions une révision du
plan pandémie avec notamment
l'amélioration de la gestion des stocks
l'importance de mettre l'accent sur la
recherche française et les formations
dans le domaine de la santé publique
mais aussi la prévention des risques
infectieux pour le professeur didier
pittet la france est actuellement à 50%
d'immunité pour lui un objectif de 80 %
seraient nécessaires pour attendre une
immunité collective
et justement pour en parler nous avons
le plaisir d'accueillir didier pitt et
coauteur du rapport éponyme bonsoir dit
dépité merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
vous êtes infectiologues et
épidémiologistes et président de la
mission donc d'indépendants entre sur
l'évaluation de gestion de la crise kobe
19 en france une grave d'ailleurs nous a
présenté un petit peu votre rapport a
tenté voie d'être synthétique parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de choses j'ai une
question qu'est ce qui vous a le plus
surpris ou choquer vous dans cette
gestion de la crise quand vous avez
réalisé le cas français écoutez tout
dépend de la manière dont on se place si
on fait une comparaison internationale
ou bien sûr se plonge intimes ou dans ce
qui s'est passé en france est ce qui
vous intéresse avant tout évidemment
c'est ce que nous avons pu retirer de
nos entretiens on a fait plus de 200
entretiens on a eu accès à tout le
matériel que nous aurions voulu
consulter
on a réussi à ne pas avoir aucune des
experts aucun link une des personnes qui
que nous
on voir qu'ils sont venus au fond suivre
nos interviews donc non plus travaillé
dans de magnifiques conditions cette
mission est très exceptionnel
puisqu'elle a en même temps étudié le
sanitaire l'économique et le social qui
est tout à fait unique ces promos le
premier pays qu'il l'a fait et nous
avons dû rendre ce rapport
suite au fait que l'organisation
mondiale de l'eau ms demandait que
chaque pays fassent de même et que nous
restitue pour l'organisation mondiale de
la santé qui démarre son assemblée
mondiale la semaine prochaine dans ces
conditions là on fait que will nous
sommes penchés sur la situation de près
et pour essayer de comprendre et surtout
pour essayer d'améliorer ce qui pourrait
être amélioré il ya une transformation
formidable de la gestion de cette crise
un pays qui est un pays centralisé qui a
su territorialisées et ça ça a été un
aspect extrêmement positif de la de
l'évaluation
si je peux me permettre ans a mis du
temps quand même cette
territorialisation on n'a pas constaté
dans les premiers mois du virus en il a
fallu attendre la deuxième partie de
l'année n'est ce pas tout à fait mais a
contrario dans les pays comme le mien la
suisse ou l'allemagne qui sont des pays
par définition qui travaillent de
manière fédérative donc où chaque canton
où chaque länder travail à sa façon il a
fallu centraliser pour que les actions
soient bonnes dents voyez il n'y a pas
de système et des ah mais vous avez
raison
cette territorialisation a pris un
certain temps mais aujourd'hui elle est
effective elle fonctionne bien et je
crois que celle de voir ce changement de
au plan de la gestion est quelque chose
de très important est évidemment notre
message principal votre reportage là
bien là bien dit c'est que l'autre
recommandation première qui est basé sur
une série de recommandations comme vous
l'avez dit nous en avons fait 40 mail
dizaine qui s'adresse à la
santé publique pour une transformation
de la santé publique française qui est
existante mais qui montrent
d'intelligence collective et de travail
en commun de mise en commun des
ressources et des décisions avec
certainement eu un excès souvent
d'administrative à sion je dirais des
décisions mais tout ça c'est quelque
chose qui est certainement connu de
l'organisation en france justement dit
d'éviter cette transformation de la
santé publique est ce que vous avez
constaté dans votre travail immense à
une évolution c'est de cette santé
publique avant le virus est maintenant
est ce qu'il ya eu une amélioration sur
ce plan est indéniablement vous savez
tout les santé publique sont en général
dans tous les pays du monde un peu les
parents pauvres non seulement de la
médecine mais également savait que la
santé publique implique aussi les
sciences vétérinaires l'essence de
l'environnement la santé globale en
général mais nous avons vu les
changements ou luisa pour vous les avez
vu vous même vous avez vu la capacité
d'aidé à grèce de se transformer en
organe de terrain qui sont proches du
terrain pour comprendre les chaînes de
transmission donc nous avons vu des
changements mais il ya encore beaucoup
de changements à à réaliser en matière
d'épidémiologie de terrain et un terme
un tout petit peu barbare mais ça veut
dire simplement de s'approcher
d'expliquer à celles et ceux qui doivent
nécessairement adopter les bonnes
pratiques pour prévenir la transmission
de ce virus
il n'ya pas évidemment que la
vaccination qui est fondamentalement
importante tout le monde l'aura compris
mais également évidemment le respect des
mesures barrières le respect de du test
le respect de la consigne d'isolement
par exemple donc on voit bien des
changements on voit clairement des
changements en france on peut faire
certainement dieu comme d'ailleurs dans
tous les pays du monde il faut bien le
reconnaître sans par me pardonnez moi
parvenir vos 40 propositions à vous
mettez l'accent sur l'importance de la
recherche française notamment pour les
vaccins cela vous a choqué qu'un
laboratoire comme sanofi hopping pasteur
ne soit pas encore sur le marché
non ça nous a d abord tout d'abord déçu
parce que on connaît la force de sanofi
qui est une des meilleures meilleurs des
meilleurs groupes au monde pour produire
des vaccins en particulier par exemple
contre la grippe je crois que attention
sanofi n'a pas dit son dernier mot il ya
encore un vaccin qui est en préparation
et il est certainement extrêmement
intéressant nous n'avons pas pu faire
une analyse complète de la recherche en
france c'était un tout petit peu en
dehors des marches de la mission est
peut-être que certains vont nous trouver
un peu complaisant dans ce sens là et
nous aurions a dû avoir probablement
encore d'autres entretiens encore une
autre approche pour le faire mais oui à
quelque part il y as certainement la
place pour une forte réflexion sur la
mission de la recherche et de
l'innovation en france mais je laisserai
probablement cette cache à une prochaine
mission
vous savez tous les pays du monde ont à
faire des progrès et chaque pays devrait
faire cette mission telle qu'elle a été
réalisée en france nous serons
certainement la première démission a
rapporté à l'assemblée mondiale de la
santé lundi prochain on est on espère ne
pas trop de missions sur ce type de
virus en tout de même dit dépité vous
vous dites que tout le monde a été long
y compris l' oms
comment expliquer qu'une organisation
mondiale dont c'est quand même voilà le
dessin de s'occuper de deux crises
sanitaires de santé mondiale comment
expliquer qu'elle ait été aussi aux
lentes précisément écoutez c'est un peu
compliqué la gouvernance de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé est
en révision depuis de nombreuses années
en tout cas depuis le temps que je
travaille en collaboration avec cette
organisation ce qui fait plus de 25 ans
et au fond lorsqu'on est en état de
crise et tout le monde l'a vu dans tous
les pays du monde
évidemment c'est comme utiliser un
projecteur qui va signaler au fond
certains des défauts voire même beaucoup
des défauts et ses chaussures au fond ce
qui s'est passé l'om s est très
dépendante de la volonté des pays
créé et peut-être trop politisé il est
temps certainement de transformer cette
cette organisation mondiale de la santé
qui souffrent vous l'avez eu aussi d'un
budget pratiquement ridicule par rapport
à sa mission et donc il est temps aussi
du côté de l'organisation mondiale de la
santé de fer 7
cette analyse en profondeur cette de
tirer les leçons de cette crise pour
continuer à améliorer le système il ya
des choses qui ont bien marché la
consultation des experts
mais il ya d'autres choses qui ont moins
bien marché dans la rapidité de réponse
que nous avons dit aussi c'est que
l'europe de la santé était totalement
absente au début de la crise c'est
rattraper ensuite mais là aussi il y
aura des progrès à faire
donc il faut être très humble par
rapport à cette situation que personne
n'avait connu auparavant
aucun état aucun cher des cas aucun
ministre de santé dans le monde n'avait
eu à gérer une telle situation
restons humbles mais apprenons
évidemment de la crise pour faire mieux
tout de suite à moyen terme
et puis pour la prochaine fois même si
personne ne l'espère mais elle arrivera
une fois bien entendu dernière petite
question un petit peu poil à gratter
pourquoi avoir demandé un infectiologue
suisse de faire ce rapport pourquoi pas
un français pour votre légendaire
neutralité peut-être il faut le demander
à l'exécutif français je ne peux pas je
ne peux pas répondre à cette question
merci en tout cas dit dépité on était
ravi de vous avoir merci de nous avoir
consacré ces quelques minutes lors de la
remise donc aujourd'hui de votre rapport
merci à vous j - avant la réouverture
des terrasses des bars et des
restaurants l'heure des préparatifs
notre reporter bassem séville est allé à
la rencontre du patron de chez mézilles
un bistrot dans le 19e arrondissement de
paris
comment va-t-il rentabiliser sa première
journée avec seulement 50 % de sa
clientèle habituelle
dernière étape avant la réouverture
quasi complète le 9 juin
témoignage on s'installe sans savoir
exactement comment s'installer donc on
est en train de faire des essais là on a
une jauge à 50% mais 50% de quoi c'est
pas très très clair il l'année dernière
on avait cette distance de 1 mètre entre
les tables donc on est pas mal de
restaurateurs
le prix le parti pris de de repartir sur
cette distanciation la 1 m entre les
tables mais c'est compliqué parce que
selon que ça soit des groupes on va
déplacer les tables voilà les gens vont
venir s'installer
on va pas pouvoir travailler comme si on
fonctionnait
normalement donc on est un peu dans la
confusion il ya déjà des confrères à moi
qu ont reçu des visites de la police qui
leur dit que c'est pas comme ça il nous
demande sur quel décret ils s'appuient
aujourd'hui n'y a pas de décret qui sont
parus donc ça risque de créer des
tensions
on sort d'une période très compliquée on
est encore dans une période compliquée
et cette confusion
rajoutons compliqué alors de toute façon
avec une chose à 50% on a un manque à
gagner de 50 % voilà c'est c'est clair
donc on se doutait que dans un premier
temps on allait avoir quelque chose
d'évolutif on l'a on l'a intégré mais on
n'est pas encore ce qu'on veut pas nous
c'est avoir des problèmes avec
la police et cetera voilà vraiment qu'on
soit sûr des discussions de on a droit
de faire ça on n'a pas le droit de faire
ça et aujourd'hui le texte qui est sorti
enfin les consignes qui ont été données
par le gouvernement ne sont pas très
claires et c'est la confusion un peu
total comme pour les contres terrassa
remettra en patois des toits etc
rien n'est clair moi j'ai stoppé les
réservations à 40 et le reste je prends
au fur et à mesure voilà parce qu'en
plus demain malheureusement on va pas
avoir un soleil comme ça a priori on va
plutôt avoir un temps orageux mois avec
la en respectant les normes sanitaires
ça me fait une terrasse d'environ 100
places donc j'ai réservé 40 places et il
y en aura une soixantaine pour pour les
personnes qui vont passer faut savoir
qu'en plus ça on va avoir le droit de
fermeture à 21h donc c'est un petit peu
compliqué aussi
parce que les gens veulent réserver
assez tard on ne peut pas sortir sans
couverts
de la cuisine pour en une demi heure
voilà donc c'est pour ça aussi qu'on va
être obligé de jouer un petit peu sur
surtout mais en tout cas on sait qu'à
21h les derniers clients d'avoir payé
cette levée de table cette ouverture à
21h nous on se projette déjà dans trois
semaines
à 23 heures où effectivement on va
pouvoir commencer à faire des vrais
services voilà et puis surtout au mois
de juillet où normalement on devrait
pouvoir retravailler
sans contrainte c'est à dire arrêter
nous les patrons d'avoir un patron qui
nous dit toutes les semaines ou tous les
quinze jours fait ceci fait pas cela
fait ceci fait pas cela nous on gère on
gère la vie économique de nos
entreprises ont géré la survie nos
entreprises on gère les on gère nos
salariés et on a quelqu'un qui nous
donne des directives complètement
différente ou de directives qui sont pas
très précises et donc on a vraiment
envie de reprendre notre notre vie
d'avant et gérer nos entreprises prendre
nos risques
si ça ne marche pas les assumer
aujourd'hui on assume des risques qui ne
sont pas ceux que nous on a pris le
déconfinement qui pourrait bien libérer
des envies et notamment celle de voyager
à châteauroux l'aéroport n'a jamais été
autant occupé comme parking avions une
manne pendant la pandémie pour cette
plateforme mais si le trafic reprenait
il faudrait un peu de temps avant qu'un
avion ne redécolle maxime hébert avec
bilal oiseaux ils viennent de partout
dans le monde
la pandémie les a cloués au sol pour une
durée indéterminée
certains attendent un retour du trafic
d'autres sont en maintenance 43 avions
sur le tarmac de l'aéroport de
châteauroux
pour son directeur c'est du jamais vu je
travaille sur le site de l'aéroport
depuis 2004 et je n'ai jamais connu
autant d'avions au parking sur sur notre
site évidemment la crise qu vide est
passé par ici
tous ces avions ne pouvant plus volés il
a fallu leur trouver de la place on a la
chance de par notre histoire puisque
l'aéroport châteauroux centre était
auparavant l'une des plus importantes
bases logistiques de l'otan entre 1951
et 1967 et cette installation nous
permet de profiter de 25 hectares de
parking à châteauroux les prix de
location de parking aussi entre 3000 et
5000 euros par mois très compétitif
l'aéroport attire un grand nombre de
compagnies à tel point que la british
airways avait stationné 11 de ses airbus
a380 sur les douze qu'elle possède un
moyen de limiter les coûts pour les
compagnies d'autant que nul ne sait
quand le trafic reprendra mais le
directeur reste optimiste en ce qui
concerne la le départ de ses avions
c'est un peu l'inconnu pour l'instant
même si les choses commencent à se
préciser on ne sait pas vraiment quand
ces avions repartiront tout comme
beaucoup de nos clients
moi je suis convaincu que ça va
redémarrer très très vite après pour
quelle durée
ça c'est encore l'inconnu les
entreprises de maintenance ont dû
augmenter leur personnel pour faire face
à la demande
car si le trafic repart vite il faut du
temps pour démobiliser un avion
tous les avions ont été prises en charge
dans le cadre d'une maintenance
préventive en fonction de la durée
pendant laquelle l'avion est resté au
sol
you need il faut une à deux semaines
pour remettre un avion en service il y a
beaucoup de travail à faire il faut voir
s'il ya suffisamment de main d'oeuvre de
pièces de rechange et d'outils
si le trafic reprend l'activité de
parking de l'aéroport pourrait diminuer
mais la plateforme aéroportuaire a
d'autres atouts
le fret la maintenance et l'entraînement
des pilotes pourrait reprendre avec le
retour de la croissance
et pourquoi pas le transport de
voyageurs
une idée envisagée avec la crise
l'aéroport de châteauroux se voit
pousser des ailes
et ailleurs dans le monde au sénégal où
l'on dénombre un peu plus de 1000 morts
et 40 mille contamination le commis 19 a
bouleversé la vie de milliers de femmes
en cause la fermeture des marchés locaux
et internationaux à cause du virus
yamina benhaïda à barney petite ville du
sénégal située sur la côte à une
trentaine de kilomètres de dakar ndèye
dao diouf comme des milliers d'autres
femmes s'adonnent à la transformation du
poisson depuis des décennies transformer
le poisson est le maillon essentiel
d'une chaîne qui constitue l'une des
principale source d'exportation du pays
avec la pandémie due qu'aux vives 19 le
quotidien de ces travailleuses a été
bouleversé le coc vite 19 a beaucoup
affecté le travail parce que pendant le
coc vide
je ne travaillais pas et je devais
rester à la maison parfois mon mari
allait en mer pour pêcher du poisson
mais parfois il ne le faisait pas où ils
n'obtenaient rien c'est lui qui
travaillait pour amener de la nourriture
à la maison je ne pouvais pas sortir il
n'y avait pas d'argent
ici la vie est rythmée par l'activité
halieutique et ce n'est pas un hasard
car pour les habitants de barney la
transformation du poisson n'est pas
seulement un travail c'est aussi un
héritage d'une pierre noire souillée et
réputé la transformation de mes parents
et mes grands-parents mais mon père
était pêcheur
donc nous ne savons que le poisson donc
la classe formation c'est une fierté
c'est mme affret a fait parce que je
suis né au mans baptisé de l'argent de
pêche
alors qu'en temps normal la
transformation de poisson peut rapporter
jusqu'à 500 mille francs cfa soit
environ 760 euros
l'année dernière elle a rapporté très
peu parfois rien du tout les nouvelles
restrictions sanitaires et la méfiance
vis-à-vis du virus ont considérablement
ralenti l'activité de ces femmes qui
font tourner l'économie de toute la côte
sénégalaise
une femme qui travaille ici nourrit
environ 7 8 personnes de sa famille et
de son entourage
je ne parle pas seulement de ses propres
enfants mais de ses tantes de son
grand-père de toute une communauté
qu'elle nourrit aussi voulu enlever
cette économie si vous enlevez cette
partie du travail
si vous lui imposez des projets dont
l'impact pourrait être négative sur sa
vie cela aura une influence sur des
milliers de vies autour d'elle
ce n'est pas seulement une personne mais
plusieurs qui vont perdre des revenus
indirectement parce que cette femme ne
travaille plus au sénégal le poisson
représente plus de la moitié des
protéines consommées par ces 16 millions
d'habitants ce qui est essentiel pour la
sécurité alimentaire en partie à cause
du coc vide 19
en 2020 la contribution de la pêche dans
le pib du pays a diminué de 30 4,9 pour
cent le mois dernier la première
véritable saison de pêche depuis la
pandémie a démarré apportant un nouvel
espoir aux transformateurs à leurs
familles et aux villages dans quelques
instants rester avec nous partirons en
espagne à ceuta précisément où 6000
migrants sont entrés dans l'enclavé à la
frontière du maroc hier le président
espagnol s'est rendu sur les lieux et
puis à paris les habitants du quartier
stalingrad
épuisé par les nuisances sonores dues
aux toxicomanes les collines du crack
aménagé par la police nous en
discuterons avec nos invités
[Musique]
la repentance est un sentiment aux
conséquences extrêmement graves pour
l'avenir
cette pratique obsessionnel s'imposant
l'esprit de nos dirigeants comme la
condition incontournable d'une
gouvernance responsable moderne plutôt
que de se repentir
on ferait mieux de faire référence à un
passé dont on peut être fier
nous trouvons un autre exemple des
limites de cette transparence dans
l'utilisation de la raison d'état pour
cacher la vérité sous la pression
médiatique et la raison d'état on
pratique une sélection du bien et du mal
à géométrie variable
il faut sauver la liberté d'expression
qui est prise en otage dans une
inversion entre le juste et le cas
[Musique]
un féminicide et commis tous les deux à
trois jours en france actuellement
pourquoi il shoote ont encore à protéger
totalement les femmes on dit souvent
femme posée en parler briser le silence
nous savons que seulement 18 19 % des
femmes révèle les violences qu'elles
subissent donc ça veut dire qu'il ya 80%
de femmes qui ne révèle pas les
violences qu'elles subissent aux forces
de sécurité
donc celle qui rêvait il faut vraiment
les croix et les protéger souvent on met
toute la responsabilité sur la victime
c'est la question de quels sont les
moyens que l'agresseur a mis en oeuvre
qui doit être posée et la loi le dis
très clairement
et souvent on détourne la loi par cette
histoire de consentement on voit bien
qu'on est quand même encore très loin
très loin de ce qui est nécessaire pour
vraiment pouvoir avoir les moyens de
protéger les femmes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
21h30 soyez les bienvenus en direct sur
rt france si vous nous rejoignez depuis
le début de la semaine nuit mille
migrants ont débarqué sur l'enclavé
espagnole de ceuta au nord ouest du
maghreb madrid qui a convoqué
l'ambassadrice marocaine a déjà annoncé
avoir expulsé quatre mille personnes
le dispositif de sécurité a été renforcé
en conséquence le maroc rappelle à son
tour son ambassadrice en consultation
hélène masquelier les plages de ceuta
sous un vent de chaos
une véritable marée humaine a déferlé
depuis le début de la semaine sur les
côtes de l'enclavé espagnole venue du
maroc des milliers d'hommes de femmes et
d'enfants ont gagné le territoire situé
au nord ouest du maghreb à l'aide de
bouées gonflables ou de canots
pneumatiques
face à cet afflux à l'ampleur inédite le
gouvernement espagnol a vivement réagi
le premier ministre espagnol a promis
l'expulsion des migrants
ma priorité en tant que président du
gouvernement espagnol est actuellement
de garantir le contrôle du transit à la
frontière avec le maroc et de procéder
au retour immédiat je le répète au
retour immédiat de tous ceux qui sont
entrés irrégulièrement à ceuta et
mellila comme le prévoient les accords
que l'espagne a signé avec le maroc
depuis des années pour l'exécutif
l'urgence est de mise et la réponse ne
manque pas de fermeté le dispositif de
sécurité a été lourdement renforcée
aujourd'hui les premiers renforts de la
police nationale et de la garde civile
arrive
il s'agit de 200 agents qui s'ajoutent
aux 1100 agents que nous avons en
permanence sur le terrain
ceuta et mellila constituent les seules
frontières terrestres de l'union
européenne avec l'afrique
un afflux migratoire qui pourrait avoir
des conséquences sur l'ensemble de
l'union européenne selon le gouvernement
espagnol
bruxelles de son côté a partagé son
inquiétude face à cette catastrophe
humanitaire
il est inquiétant de constater qu'au
moins 6000 personnes dont un grand
nombre d'enfants ont rejoint ceuta à la
nage mettant ainsi leur vie en danger
la chose la plus importante maintenant
et que le maroc continue à s'engager à
prévenir les départs d'irrégulier ce
nombreux records d'arrivée survient en
pleine crise diplomatique entre
l'espagne et le maroc alors que rabat
est traditionnellement un allié clef de
madrid dans la lutte contre
l'immigration clandestine
les relations entre les deux pays se
sont tendues depuis l'accueil fin avril
par l'espagne du chef des
indépendantistes sahraouis pour être
soigné du coc vite 19
une décision qui a déclenché la colère
de rabat madrid de son côté accuse le
maroc d'avoir laissé faire pour punir
l'espagne de ce soutien présumé aux
front polisario en guise de mise au
point
l'ambassadrice marocaine vient d'être
convoqué par le ministère des affaires
étrangères espagnol et on en parle tout
de suite avec adnan ahmad avocate
spécialiste droits des migrants bonsoir
madame merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france au tout d'abord première
question qu'est ce qui va advenir de
tous et s'est réfugié 4000 ont déjà été
expulsés vers le maroc
bonsoir alors je pense que nous avons
entendu le premier ministre espagnol
clairement ce qui va en advenir c'est un
événement immédiat un refoulement
immédiat cmo
comme il l'a déjà été fait avec la
moitié puisqu'il est à lancer qui a eu
déjà 4000 refoulement donc je pense que
le premier ministre va rester dans cette
lignée de fermeté liés de fermeté qui
est très importante pour l'union
européenne pour ne pas envoyer de
message je dirais de de tolérance ou
tout simplement d'acceptation de la
situation qui a été laissée faire part
par les autorités marocaines
donc je pense que c'est un message de
fermeté et j'imagine que le nombre de
refoulement va augmenter dans les
prochains les prochaines heures les
prochains jours alors qu'il faut
préciser le maroc a avait laissé faire
durant environ 24 heures c'est bien cela
oui alors c'est certain images ont pu
circuler
clairement les autorités marocaines ont
laissé faire puisqu'il ya eu certaines
personnes certains migrants qui ont été
tout simplement entendu qu'ils ont
indiqué avoir vu des messages sur les
réseaux sociaux des messages sur
facebook notamment indiquant qu' il
faisait passer la frontière
donc les autorités marocaines ne pouvait
pas l'ignorer puisque si les messages
qui étaient publics à un tel poids il ya
eu un nombre donc des milliers de
passages en quelques heures c'est que
les autorités marocaines non seulement
ont laissé faire mais peut-être en
laissait faire je dirais volontairement
et ont laissé en tout cas le message
circuler sur les réseaux sociaux
en cause les bisbilles autour du front
polisario c'est ça c'est bien ça c'est
un règlement de compte d'une certaine
manière
alors ils sont beaux mais effectivement
qu'il s'agit qui êtes qu'il s'agisse
d'un règlement de compte pour moi je
pense que le maroc est en train de faire
du chantage est en train d'envoyer un
message clair
à l'union européenne mais la
spécifiquement à l'espagne de montrer
que sans une coopération et sans un
maintien des liens diplomatiques je
dirais avec des liens très étroits le
maroc peut faire mal en matière
d'immigration
puisque il faut rappeler que ces ulta et
mellila c'est la seule frontière avec
avec l'afrique que directement sur sur
l'europe donc ce sont deux villes
oui impérativement maintenir la
coopération avec le maroc le maroc le
sait le maroc s'est effectivement que
l'union européenne ah je dirais comme
priorités notamment ces dernières années
de pouvoir réguler l'immigration
illégale
donc ils sont en train d'utiliser le
moyen le plus je dirais le plus
dangereux pour l'union européenne à
savoir soit vous maintenez les miens les
liens diplomatiques
soit on va effectivement laisser faire
au niveau des passages et c'est ce qui a
été fait pendant quelques heures
imaginez si durant quelques heures il ya
eu plus de huit passages ce qui peut
être fait à long terme si le maroc
décidé d'une épée effectivement coopérer
effectivement l'europe qui exprime sa
solidarité avec l'espagne qui dit qu
elle a besoin de solutions communes pour
la gestion de l'immigration elle
appelait cela 20 dans les hyènes à un
accord sur la réforme de la politique
migratoire aujourd'hui clairement que
stipulent les accords migratoires entre
l'espagne et le maroc
alors il y a des accords migratoires
entre l'espagne et le maroc mais aussi
des accords au niveau de l'union
européenne
la difficulté c'est que l'espagne tout
comme l'italie sans des pays qui sont
immédiatement je dirais débit d'entrée
et l'union européenne peine à trouver
une politique commune en matière
d'immigration une politique commune qui
serait égalitaire c'est à dire de
pouvoir recevoir et de pouvoir aider les
pays qui reçoivent le plus haut niveau
de l'immigration et de pouvoir tout
simplement après dispatcher les
demandeurs d'asile dans les pays de
l'union européenne de manière alors
peut-être pas égalité 1-1 en tout cas de
manière plus équitable que ce qui se
passe actuellement puisque la grèce
l'italie et l'espagne sont les pays qui
reçoivent en entrée en premier les
migrants il y à des sommes d'argent
assez importante puisque l'union
européenne à renforcer son appui avec le
maroc qui a doté de plusieurs millions
de plus de 300 millions d'euros
le programme au niveau de l'immigration
mais il semblerait je pense également
avec ce que vient de faire le maroc
c'est à dire de laisser passer les
migrants qu' il y a aussi une volonté du
maroc de vouloir avoir peut-être
davantage de fonds et de dotation et
surpris davantage d'équipements deçà il
ils ont ils ont clairement déjà indiqué
d'avoir davantage d'équipements pour
lutter contre l'immigration
alors certains de ces migrants on
l'entendait 1,10 et en perse et ceuta ou
ou la mort tous sont ils ces migrants
qui viennent du maroc
pourquoi fuite il alors je pense qu'il
faut distinguer les migrants qui sont
arrivés les dernières heures cas au
niveau de ces états qui sont
essentiellement des migrants originaires
du maroc et les migrants qui ont pu
entrer par mille îles a qui sont eux par
contre essentiellement des migrants qui
peuvent arriver
de l'afrique subsaharienne donc il ya
deux à ce niveau là il faut il faut
distinguer les deux les migrants que
l'on voit sur les vidéos et que l'on
voit effectivement arriver les dernières
heures par ceuta cent essentiellement
des des migrants qui viennent du maroc
et qui ont eu l'information de ce point
de passage alors ce sont des personnes
on peut pas effectivement donné une de
manière homogène leur parcours mais on a
pu en a pu lire qu'il y avait des femmes
qui sont au chômage qui sont dans la
détresse parce qu'il y a il ya beaucoup
d'enfants beaucoup d'enfants près de
près d'un tiers de ces migrants seraient
effectivement des démineurs
donc ce sont des mineurs qui ont envie
simplement de rêver d'un monde meilleur
en se disant qu'il ya pas de travail pas
d'avenir dans leur pays au maroc et qui
a envie de passer la frontière pour
tenter d'avoir un monde meilleur mais a
aussi on l'a vu des femmes qui elles
sont dans la détresse dans la précarité
peut-être en raison de leur statut
social donc souvent des femmes qui sont
au chômage qui ont des enfants qu'elle
élève seule et qui on vit également
effectivement de de donner une meilleure
vie à l'heure à leur famille donc les
migrants aujourd'hui qui sont passés à
melilla entre le 17 et le 18 mai sans
excuser moi un soldat entre les 17e
jésus mais eux sont essentiellement des
migrants je dirais économique
non non pas des demandeurs d'asile à mon
sens qui eux sont davantage glacé au
niveau de 2010 la merci en tout cas on
retiendra un tiers de mineurs merci anne
hannspad avocate spécialiste du droit
des migrants d'avoir été avec nous sur
rt france
pour le retour en france avec le verdict
qui vient de tomber dans la sphère
karine jambes ou sept dernières victimes
de viols pendant son enfance à attaquer
l'état pour faire reconnaître la
culpabilité des instances judiciaires
incapable de la place est loin de son
agresseur en fait le point avec katia
pet food
le délibéré très attendue est tombée
l'état a été condamné pour ses fautes
lourdes le jugement donne donc raison
sur toute la ligne à la plaignante
karine jambu âgé aujourd'hui de 23 ans
en première instance en 2018 l'état
n'avait été condamné que pour déni de
justice
aujourd'hui il est également condamné
pour faute lourde et devra indemniser
karine jambu hauteur environ 200000
euros
en effet les services de l'état avaient
négligé les plaintes et divers
signalements au sujet de viols répétés
de karine jean bus lorsqu'elle était une
petite fille à partir de 2002 à rennes
de ces 4 à 7 ans karine jambes yeux
étaient violées au domicile de ses
parents par un homme un voisin qui était
déjà condamné pour faits pédocriminels
la mère de karine jambu avait assassiné
son propre bébé à coups de poignard
quelques années auparavant avait été
condamné pour cela et bien lorsque les
10 signalements ont été faits et malgré
ce contexte extrêmement inquiétant le
parquet de rennes avait classé l'affairé
sans suite finalement une enquête
préliminaire a été ouverte mais il a
fallu attendre 17 mois pour qu'un juge
d'instruction soit nommé
alors aujourd'hui après des années de
combat judiciaire ce délibéré vient
confirmer les immenses raté des rouages
de la protection de l'enfance dans le
cas de karim jambu une décision sans
précédent
ils sont épuisés les habitants du
quartier de stalingrad dans le 19e
arrondissement de paris ils en ont assez
des nuisances sonores causées par les
consommateurs de crack pour alerter sur
leur situation les riverains tapent sur
des casseroles tous les soirs la police
a donc décidé de regrouper les
toxicomanes dans un square le jardin
d'eole un site qui n'est pas inconnu
pour eux puisque c'est ici qu'il passe
les journées les forces de l'ordre lé
surveilleront jusqu'à une heure du matin
et s'assureront qu'il ne revienne pas
s'y installer après la fermeture du parc
une solution temporaire selon la
préfecture
mais est-ce justement vraiment la bonne
solution c'est l'objet de notre face à
face ce soir et pour en débattre pierre
lycia porte parole du mouvement libre
bonsoir pierre lys ya à vos côtés
frédéric france elle membre du collectif
19 un collectif citoyen du 19e
arrondissement frédérique france l on
avait eu le plaisir de vous il ya
quelques semaines c'était à l'époque où
les habitants commençaient à attirer des
tirs de mortiers un pas vous mais bon
certains tellement qu'il n'en pouvait
plus depuis les migrants apparemment par
les migrants pardonnez moi excusez moi
aucun lien
les consommateurs de crack ont été
regroupés dans le parc la nuit est ce
que ça améliorer les choses oui ou non
je laisse d'être fairy que qu'on n'a pas
envie qu'ils habitent personne ne dit on
pas qu'on puisse dire que ça et
améliorer les choses
je pense surtout que ça déplacé le
problème ça a déplacé le problème depuis
stalingrad jusqu'à actuellement donc le
jardin d'eole la nuit mais ça n'a pas
changé vraiment l'acier le problème elle
savait dire que la situation est
toujours aussi pénible pour vous
riverains expliquez nous comment comment
ça se passe mais temps ce qui a eu une
évolution depuis la dernière fois qu'on
vous a parlé
alors depuis les infos vous ai parlé il
ya eu un petit peu plus de forces de
police qui ont été déployés dans le
quartier
nous avons vu effectivement apparaître
des cars de crs des cartes des gendarmes
mobiles qui font un petit peu plus de de
marotte je dirais enfin qui se vendent
problème un peu plus dans le quartier la
très récemment ont depuis deux jours on
a vu qu'il y avait effectivement des
mouvements vers le jardin de l'école où
il ya eu enfin taux de l'installation de
barrières voulons on a vu effectivement
que le jardin s'ouvrait à partir de 19h
mais une seulement une petite partie
on n'est pas vraiment sûr que ça
améliore les choses on a vu qu
effectivement il y avait des nouvelles
forces de police donc
ça fait évoluer par contre est-ce que
c'est une bonne évolution est ce que ça
a évolué dans le bon sens ou pas j'ai un
peu en août
on a l'impression surtout qu'ils ont
déplacé le problème de stalingrad
jusqu'à école parce qu à stalingrad
il y a du monde et que parfois il peut y
avoir les restos qui vont rouvrir les
cinémas qui vont rouvrir à eole n'ya pas
de cinéma il n'y a pas de resto donc par
contre il ya beaucoup de riverains
donc les riverains peut-être sont un peu
sacrifié au profit de ceux qui ne sont
pas arrivés et ont peut-être besoin de
se détendre je sais pas ce qui se passe
exactement mais je suis un peu sceptique
d'accord il n'est pas question de
sacrifier les jardins d'eole a assuré
marc dié de la mairie tient les cja
quand vous entendez le récit de frédéric
france elle vous vous dites quoi on
imagine cette colère des habitants
oui moi une colère d'ailleurs que je
partage parce que j'habite je suis
riverains aussi du quartier j'évite de
l'autre côté en fête des jardins d'eole
donc c'est une problématique que je
connais malheureusement très bien et et
frédéric foncel l'a très bien dit on a
déplacé le problème c'est ça la réalité
on a déplacé le problème et ça fait
malheureusement ça fait pas quelques
semaines ça fait pas quelques mois ça
fait trois ans que les pouvoirs publics
déplace le problème il faut quand même
se souvenir que les toxicomanes étaient
présents en masse il ya quelques années
2018-2019 porte de la chapelle sur la
fameuse colline du crack et après et
après plusieurs mois de battage
médiatique aussi autour de la colline du
crack les les pouvoirs publics la
préfecture à l'époque avait procédé au
démantèlement de la colline sauf que
quand vous démentez la colline vous
éparpiller les toxicomanes dans le
quartier et c'est exactement ce qui
s'est passé tant que les toxicomanes ne
sont pas prises en charge dans le cadre
d'une prise en charge sanitaire au long
cours il n'ya pas d'autre choix pour eux
que de rester dans le quartier donc
c'est c'est ainsi que depuis trois ans
il lit les airs malheureusement de
quartier en quartier dans le nord-est
par exemple entre la porte de la
chapelle entre la porte d'aubervilliers
stalingrad jusqu'à tout récemment
et aujourd'hui la décision qui est prise
et non pas d'assurer une prise en charge
pour sortir le quartier de cette ornière
de cette impasse de cet enfer mais mais
mais la décision est prise de finalement
parquet les toxicomanes dans un espace
qui est un jardin pour enfants
moi je veux bien qu'on dise qu'il ya
moins d'habitants et moins d'habitants à
rôles qu à stalingrad
nous avons un jardin pour enfants qui
est immense si un jardin pour enfants ça
veut dire que nous allons dans un
quartier résidentiel que nous nous
sommes dans un quartier où il ya des
familles que nous sommes dans un
quartier où il ya a fortiori des enfants
et bien les pouvoirs publics font le
choix font le choix par cette décision
de sacrifier à la fois cet espace vert
qui d'ailleurs si vous regardez le site
de la ville de paris n'est plus
comptabilisé aujourd'hui n'est plus
répertorié aujourd'hui comme un espace
vert de la ville de paris mais c'est
désormais une salle de shoot à ciel
ouvert où on autorise la consommation de
crack et le deal est évidemment
évidemment pour les riverains de tout le
quartier pas simplement de la rue
d'aubervilliers du jardin des halles
pour tous le tout mais quartier qui
jouxte le jardin d'eole donc une grande
partie du nord est parisien et une
quartier stalingrad et bien c'est un
enfer et et le pire dans tout ça c'est
que finalement on considère on considère
que le jardin d'eole est désormais une
place libre de deals et de consommation
de drogue on a institutionnalisé le
shoot en pleine rue et moi je trouve ça
abominable et surtout abominable pour
les riverains il propose une opération
dans les prochains jours pour éloigner
ces dealers et consommateurs de crack
qu'est ce que ça pourrait être cette
opération selon vous frédéric france
elle
vous êtes optimiste vous avez plein
d'espoir envers ces annonces du ministre
de l'intérieur plein d'optimisme et
d'espoir je suis pas vraiment certain
que ce soit les mots justes d'optimisme
peut-être effectivement puisque pour le
coup il s'intéresse à nous donc du coup
on aura peut-être effectivement là le
avantage d'avoir quelques cars de crs
supplémentaires etc
par contre ce qui m'inquiète un petit
peu moins c'est le déplacement moi je
veux bien qu'il ait des places mais il
est déplacé ou pour quoi faire
parce que s'ils les déplace uniquement
pour les mettre au milieu d'eux d'autres
riverains sans les soigner tout en les
laissant déambuler au milieu des rues et
de faire n'importe quoi c'est pas une
solution c'est pas une solution pour les
riverains non plus si ils ont prévu par
contre de les encadrer de les prendre et
de les mettre dans un lieu fermé sans
public avec je sais pas moi des moyens
fermiers psychosociaux des choses comme
ça et de les soigner tout en prenant de
l'autre côté les dealers et des
les mettant en prison a effectivement ça
pourrait être effectivement une très
bonne chose pourquoi je ne sens pas que
ce parti vert toujours dit c'est cette
tendance la pierre lys ya ce qu'on en
sait plus sur l'identité de ces
toxicomanes je faisais lien tout à
l'heure avec les migrants alors c'est
vrai qu'il ya parmi eux des migrants est
ce que c'est de là que vient toute la
difficulté justement de les encadrer
avec de les gérer on s'est tout
simplement pas où les renvoyer c'est pas
une question de ses peines de ses
peintures une question de savoir où les
renvoyer que de les prendre en charge
médicalement sanitairement c'est surtout
ça la réalité aujourd'hui en fait moi ce
qui me frappe
et ce qui me révolte c'est que
systématiquement les pouvoirs publics
quand on parle de toxicomanie de rue
considère ça comme un problème
sécuritaire uniquement et envoie au
front le ministre de l'intérieur est
donc là on à monsieur darmanin qui nous
explique que il va envoyer des forces de
sécurité pour aller quoi déplacer
évacuer les toxicomanes mort a encore
une fois comme le disait frédéric
française pour les évacuer ou pour les
dépasser ou aujourd'hui vous discutez
avec les policiers sur le terrain il ya
plusieurs il ya plusieurs centaines de
toxicomanes qui sont en errance dans les
rues du nord-est parisien les policiers
sont sur le terrain constamment mais les
policiers ne peuvent rien faire les
policiers ne peuvent rien faire face à
la diction c'est une maladie face à l'
addiction
les policiers ne peuvent rien faire et
policiers peuvent interpeller
éventuellement les dealers les policiers
peuvent intervenir en cas de risque en
cas de dégradation de l'espace public de
troubles à l'ordre public mais en cas de
maladie à savoir d'une addiction au
crack kill elky l'une des addictions les
plus violentes qui soit et les plus les
plus ravageuse qui soit les policiers ne
peuvent rien faire donc il faut arrêter
de toujours vouloir envoyer de troupes
de toujours vouloir apporter une
solution policière à un problème
sanitaire je le dis je le répète ça fait
trois ans qu'on envoie les flics
pardonnez moi de l'expression à chaque
fois sur chaque
regroupement de toxicomanes ça fait
trois ans qu'on déplace le problème
un moment il serait peut-être bon de se
poser la question de savoir à quoi bon
et se dira peut-être que le prisme de de
la situation qu'on comprend n'est pas le
nom qu'il faut changer qu'il faut
changer de paradigme et peut-être au
lieu d'entendre à chaque fois
systématiquement le ministre de
l'intérieur intervenir sur ces sujets là
peut être que monsieur véran ministre de
la santé pourrait lui aussi monté au
front en première ligne en disant qu'
ils l'ont non pas comme ils vont le
faire mais s'apprête à faire déplacer ou
parcs et des toxicomanes mais qui vont
les soigner il n'ya que en soignant les
toxicomanes qu'on arrivera à sortir le
quartier de l'ornière je le dis je le
répète s'il n'y a plus de toxicomanes
sur le terrain il n'y a plus de dealers
c'est aussi sans qu'il soit là mais
alors là on peut aussi prendre le
problème dans l'autre sens j'allais y
venir justement vous venez d'évoquer les
toxicomanes mais dit dealer frédéric
français mais ce sera ma dernière
question vous qui voyez le terrain
qu'ils avaient l'habitude pourquoi ça
peut paraître naïf comme question enfin
quand même pourquoi ça c'est aussi
compliqué de les arrêter tout simplement
en flagrant délit pour commencer alors
il ya plusieurs explications qui peuvent
être donnés je pense
la première c'est que déjà ce sont des
tout petits dealers c'est à dire il n'y
a pas de gros réseaux organisés
quasiment n'importe qui peut avec un
petit gramme de cocaïne et de trois
ingrédients supplémentaires fabriquer du
crack
donc n'importe qui dans n'importe quelle
cuisine peut arriver enfin n'importe qui
à condition d'avoir un gramme de cocaïne
évidemment peut arriver à fabriquer du
crack et donc par opportunisme essayer
d'aller en vendre il n'y a pas de raison
donc du coup sacré de tout petits petits
trafics et en plus donc ces petits
trafics peuvent être remplacés hyper
rapidement il suffit qu'il y en ait deux
qui se fasse attraper
et puis il y en a deux autres qui
arrivent directement après le deuxième
difficulté pour pouvoir les attrapé en
flagrant délit c'est qu'ils cachent leur
marchandise dans la bouche et donc du
coup quand il voit
les policiers arrivés par exemple donc
il ya deux options soit il la garde dans
la bouche et donc tu parles comme ça un
peu bizarrement je vois pas en fait un
policier allait mettre la main dans la
bouche de quelqu'un
s'il ya une caméra en fait il va ça va
pas bien se passer et si au pire ils
disent bon bah écoute et voilà on
soupçonne que vous avez quelque chose
dans la bouche on va vous emporter au
commissariat le toxicomane peut tout à
fait avaler le produit et le restituer
de façon naturelle je dirais quelques
jours après
et donc là du coup le par le produit a
disparu est donc très difficile de faire
un flagrant délit je pense
merci en tout cas à tous les deux
pierres lyciens à frédéric française
pour ce problème qui semble
malheureusement sans fin on espère que
la prochaine fois qu'on vous recevra y
aura vraiment du nouveau merci à tous
les deux c'est la fin de cette émission
prochain point complet sur l'actualité
dans cinq minutes
[Musique]
le terme banlieue voir le terme cité
c'est forcément péjoratif c'est vrai que
les médias ont un regard on va dire
assez particulier des banlieues et qui
dérange aujourd'hui et on donne sa
narration de la banlieue ça se
résoudrait cas des jeunes violents
contre une police tout ce qu'elle son
travail c'est plus compliqué que ça on
est français on est fiers de vivre dans
ces quartiers même s'il ya des
difficultés est la moindre des choses
c'est d'inscrire aussi notre empreinte
canton quand on participe à la vie de la
société et malheureusement n'y a pas
cette reconnaissance aujourd'hui je
pense que le changement viendra d'abord
à travers cette conscientisation des
citoyens des quartiers populaires on
parle également des deux zones de
reconquête républicaine
au final derrière ces mots qu'est ce qui
casse qui se cachent des politiques font
pour les gens mais sans les gens c'est à
dire qui donne cette impression de faire
de vouloir changer les choses
mais concrètement politiquement ils ne
le font pas
bienvenue à novossibirsk heures nous
sommes au bord de la volga le plus long
fleuve d'europe
nous sommes chez boxart y allons faire
connaissance
vous avez choisi le jour à bagdad alors
je suis arrivé en 2005 pour étudier
dernière poche la france était en 2011
le monde manque pas un petit peu non ah
oui c'est tous les fromages tous les
soucis sont toutes les les croissants la
pâtisserie traits de caractère des
russes qui te plaît l'amitié les gens
les gens très stylée les français ne le
savent pas je ne pensais jamais de ma
vie faire la plonge aussi me
vous pouvez me souhaiter bon courage
[Musique]
à très bientôt sur un terreau france
arrivé du coc u19 annie bon nombre
d'entreprises en difficulté comment les
sauver faut-il annuler la dette de
certaines entreprises l'annulation de la
dette aura des conséquences et il faut
le savoir
il n'aura des conséquences avec les
banques banques qui étaient déjà pas
bien en avant la crise du coc vide cette
idée de prendre en charge les les la
dette des entreprises
pour moi c'est un peu c'est plus
proportions gardées c'est un peu c'est
simple vaccin du dernier recours quoi au
final on aura exactement comme
d'habitude les mêmes qui vont payer
c'est à dire tous ceux qui payent des
impôts
monsieur bruno le maire se prend pour un
type ex il veut y passer toutes les
dettes les dettes de l'état les dettes
des entreprises etc stark
simplement si on se posait la question
de ne pas les faire
ça serait déjà pas mal
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ems a exhorté certains pays africains à
ne pas détruire les vaccins anti
qu'ovide péri mais il faut craindre une
vaccination low cost en afrique lors une
vaccination reste une vaccination savez
la vaccination ce n'est pas elle n'a pas
commencé avec la guitare
le problème ça reste quand même
l'approvisionnement est ce que c'est la
faute des pays les plus riches qui
accapare justement les productions de
l'accent où est le mécanisme de la
vaccination vous savez ça a soulevé
beaucoup d'enjeux sur la question de la
solidarité si on peut en faire plus en
terme de solidarité de partage de ces
bacs celle là c'est quelque chose
d'absolument important on sait que le
nigeria affirme qu'il élabore son propre
vaccin contre le coc vie de 19 pour en
finir avec justement la dépendance
vis-à-vis des laboratoires étrangers
que ce soit le sénégal le nigeria
l'afrique du sud beaucoup de pays en
cette ambition l'avoir amené la générale
de la santé publique au top des
priorités c'est quelque chose que nous
saluons énormément au niveau de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
[Musique]
malgré une quatrième revenu en une
semaine l'onu toujours incapable de se
prononcer sur un appel comme un cessez
le feu entre israéliens et palestiniens
en france jean cas cette demande à
israël accès rapide et sans entraves de
l'aide à gaza sur le terrain l'état
hébreu a refermé le point de passage
humanitaire de kerem shalom après
gaza après les tirs d'obus elle ses
prémices du retour de l'art de vivre à
la française comme le promet bruno le
maire plus que quelques heures à
patienter avant la réouverture des
terrasses et musées le pass anitea est
examinée cet après midi par les
sénateurs l'opposition évoque une mesure
liberticide
4000 migrants renvoyés par madrid vers
le maroc au lendemain sur les huit mille
exilés débarquer dans l'enclavé
espagnole de ceuta un afflux migratoire
jugé inquiétant par la commissaire
européenne aux affaires intérieures le
maroc de son côté décidé de rappeler son
ambassadrice soit en espagne aux
consultations
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur rtl france
si vous nous rejoignez nouvelle réunion
à huis clos aujourd'hui du conseil de
sécurité des nations unies la 4e en 8
jours et toujours pas déclaration
commune les états unis continuant de
juger qu'elle n'aiderait pas une
désescalade
plus tôt dans la journée les nations
unies qui avait appelé à ouvrir le point
de passage d'erez et ce après avoir
salué l'ouverture d'un premier couloir
humanitaire vers la bande de gaza
mais en raison de tirs d'obus le
checkpoint de kerem shalom a été refermé
par israël qui déplorent deux nouveaux
morts sur son territoire de son côté
paris par la voix de matignon appel au
calme et à permettre à l'aide
humanitaire d'être acheminée
correctement écouter
la france a appelé et appelle de façon
extrêmement ferme
l'ensemble des acteurs à mettre un terme